the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the final round of rapid chess was full
of thrills and spills that shook the
standings here in saint louis world
number two fabiano caruana stumbled
again out of the gate against the
surging richard rapport falling into a
tie with him for second place now in the
poll position after quietly handling a
strong field of competitors blitz phenom
hikaru nakamura sits perfectly poised to
write his blitz prowess to another title
challengers will clash and favorites
will fall day one of lightning fast
blitz coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to day four
of the st louis rapid and blitz here at
the st louis chess club well hikaru
nakamura cruised to a first place finish
in the rapid portion of the event but he
will need all his blitz skills in order
to hold off his chasers in fabiano
carana and richard rapport in a heavily
contested blitz field we'll jump to the
action right now in the studio with
yasser and alejandra
and we are back in the capital of
american chess and what a great day we
have ahead it's going to be fast and
furious here in the central west end in
saint louis as we bring you the fourth
leg of the grand chest towards the st
louis rapid and blitz and to bring you
all the action i'm grand master
alejandro ramirez with grand master yes
sir sarah juan alejandro a pleasure as
always to be commentating alongside you
and maurice it's been fun it's been so
much fun especially this tournament
what a roller coaster of emotions the
players have given us with only three
days in the books absolutely hello
everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the
of the saint louis rapid and blitz
it has been a wacky and crazy event
those rapid games with some terrible
howlers but some great chess as well in
particular that game of naca versus fabi
is epic but
having said all of that
take us through the leaderboard
alejandro it's precisely that game
between fabian naca that has the blitz
specialist his self-proclaimed twitch
streamer professional as first place
take a look at that 12 points a great
result there in the rapid right he is
currently one point ahead of his closest
suitors fabiano caruana with 11 points
as well as richard report with 11.
richard round three gay day three pardon
me wow coming up victory victory and
he's not going to
tie for a second a surprising one as he
was dead lost against fabiano caruana
receiving a great gift as the american
basically checkmated himself one of the
many howlers that we've seen in this
event with 50 we have wesley saw peters
middler and sam shanklin nine points out
of 18. they're going to have to put a
lot of wins together right he put any
pressure on hikaru meanwhile the
mercurial shakuyama media of having some
great games and a lot of blunders he
somehow finds himself with eight points
as well as jeffrey chong who himself
received a gift at the end of yesterday
absolutely by sham and will the real
shakriar please stand up
absolutely linear dominguez and lekwang
liam they haven't found their form
especially lanier having great day one
and then just fading away absolutely and
our format alejandro we have three round
robins that come comprise the st louis
rapid and blitz but the rapid is over
those were games in 25 for the 10 second
increment and we are moving on to the
blitz five minutes per game with only a
two second increment no draw offers
whatsoever in these tournaments they
have to vacuum the board or find a
repetition to split the point and
remember the rapids were worth two
points for a win and one point for a
draw none of that anymore then we go
back to traditional
uh scoring system one point for a win
that draws worth half a point and lost
nothing 150 thousand dollar prize fund a
very handsome price fund indeed and our
remaining schedule it's the weekend
yasser and it's gonna be fast and
furious we have nine rounds of blitz
ahead of us today and tomorrow we have
nine more 18 rounds of blitz split on
two days and if we need playoffs we will
do those immediately after the blitz
games tomorrow we are all about crowning
champions here in st louis and speaking
of champions we have to take a look at
that leaderboard even closer for that we
have our favorite gm maurice ashley well
thank you alejandro when you're playing
these events you want to be a model of
consistency that's what gets it done at
the highest level and the players were
not doing that at least most of the
field except for a couple of them who
did that on the first two days before
one of them collapsed let's take a look
at those two players fabiano caron and
ikaru nakamura they started off slowly
with a draw but then
fabi
won his game and went into a tie for
first and pretty much stayed there the
whole way you see nakamura there
remaining solid finally winning one but
he but it was fabi who won yet again in
round three to still be in a tie for
first after the first day then they
stayed in that position pretty much fabi
did slip in the early round but then he
won again and you see hikaru trying to
keep up as other pretenders started to
fail and then after day two look at that
fabian number one hikaru two points
behind but then the very first game he
ikaru stayed solid and fabi lost his
game to get caught but then fabi won
hikaru only drawing and it was the last
day last round of the day with ikaru
defeating fabi to finally overtake him
right at the very end and now be in
first place with fabi in a tie for
second as richard as we mentioned
surged and is also tied for second they
will face off two games blitz games
round two and round 11.
bobby will have to get it done as naca
is simply amazing how amazing the number
one rated player in the world at blitz
this is going to be a tall order for the
entire field to try to keep pace with
the lightning fast american but fabi
he's got to get it done he's the number
two player on the planet overall if he
wants to win his first rapid and blitz
event ever
he's got a great chance right now well
as we get started let's take a look at
the pairings alejandro remember we're
going to be focusing on one game during
the blitz we're going to keep you
updated on all the others but what a way
to start we have number two in the
standings richard report facing against
hikaru nakamura no doubt that's going to
be our standard of attention absolutely
highlight but the
second game that we want to keep our
eyes on peter svidler versus fabby on
table number one absolutely an important
one there caruana needs those points to
keep the pressure up on hikaru it's a
full point remember that a victory
doesn't guarantee any kind of league
froggy we're going to go back to one
point per win that's very important and
well the leaders a lot of them are
especially the americans playing with
the black pieces absolutely and uh what
are they playing for uh
alejandro a ton of money as 37
500 there for first place and not only
that remember it's those gct points and
i think out of all of these people it's
fabiano carona that wants all of those
13. absolutely doesn't want to enter the
sink field cup mathematically eliminated
that's right definitely wants to put the
pressure on maxime on wesley on shock
that are currently ahead of him in the
gct standings 25 000 is gonna be second
price and twenty thousand for third gc2
winner overall walks home with a hundred
thousand dollars in bonus money as we
see wesley uh so kind of faded
towards the end of the rapid he started
well that the second half of the rapid
wasn't his best performance it's not his
usual performance in the rapid you see
him actually get a bit of a lead into
this time control but he it was that
blunder against fabi who just never
really recovered after that he blundered
a full piece against fabiano caron
another one of those howlers yeah knight
f5 blundering a whole thing he had to
immediately resign when fabi captured
that knight and he wasn't able to win
after that i remember fabi's reaction
when knight f5 like no no you can't do
that can you do that no you can't no
absolutely not and we are moments away
this is going to be our captivating duel
richard report against hikaru nakamura
hikaru he is known as a blitz legend a
blitz specialist currently the number
one player in the fide rankings as far
as blitz is concerned
as the players get ready and i just
wanted to finish the thought hundred
thousand dollar bonus money for the
overall grand chess tour winner 50 000
runner up and twenty-five thousand extra
cash for third place
gct huge yes it's so big yes it is we're
talking about the person who wins the
championship and there's someone who's
very much in contention we are wondering
how he's been playing so poorly in this
event but he's very much in contention
overall his shack for the overall title
but even if he doesn't win the overall
title coming in second or third exactly
extra change in your pocket right so we
he will certainly try to do well here
and here we go here we go will we see
another nimzu indian yes we will
and will we see the classical yes we
will
and a3
hikaru being a big fan of this variation
using it not just in this tournament but
it's been many years where he has relied
on this line over and over again to
secure him many many draws at the top
level and i still remember in the rapid
where
he
got rocked by some great preparation by
shaq but he's so resourceful he found
all the right moves made a comfortable
draw
did
going back to that game that was played
between hikaru nakamoto with the black
pieces and shakira here he played knight
f3 knight bd7 g4
that was how uh shaq prepped and hikaru
since that game uh double checked
everything and yeah no actually pardon
me it was like knight f3 bishop
b7
g4 yes and
uh we also had the possibility of
playing knight of three rook d8 sorry it
was rigged e4 right
yes
that was another alternative move as
well
in e2 e4 was that was lik liam with the
white pieces against hikaru nakamura e4
g5 he sacrificed yes that knight on uh
g5 exactly as the players go through
their
tabia position from you okay
let me just put this away here for a
second
as e to e3
more traditional it's a more traditional
approach bishop takes f1 you usually
retake with the rook one of those lines
that has been analyzed already several
times the conclusion has been that it's
only equal for the white side
all right
one of the things as you look at white's
king for just a moment
and i
just about to say that one of the things
that you could do as white is recapture
with the king in order to get your
this is this is a known drop it should
be five times
four isn't it the same that they did in
the
rapid in the rapid yes king e2 all right
well uh will richard no there's no
choice or anymore
because queen d3 is
well it's not even an advantage anymore
so the first result of the day a little
bit of a huge dud um
in a draw okay enough of this game let's
see
let's switch over and by the way we have
a repeat again
of a game that was played yesterday in
the rapid it was uh
also uh this
joko piano with bishop on b2 this
reminds me of the game actually between
lanier that's what i mean
right right
uh that that was peter svidler playing
the bishop e3 jack
to turn the tables and lanier just like
oh groaned when he saw that move bishop
e3 okay d5 the whole purpose of the move
bishop b2 is to this bishop is an ambush
uh
attacking the rook on e5 and the move c4
and that was my question bishop g4 a lot
of pieces hanging
can i go
f3
f3 attacks everything but on the other
hand my dark scores are very weak yes
but i'm thinking that after f3 i'm so
happy that my pawn on a5 covers the b6
square so i can't get checked and
harassed on g1 okay i think f3 rook h5
is that
his idea whoa
that would be fun that would be cool
then comes e5 and
it's it's a mess it's a total mess but i
may not be threatening to take on f6
so i'm just thinking if rook h5
and he has very quickly played uh i
didn't catch the move but f3 and bishop
b6 is just straight up straight up
sacrificing the exchange saying my dark
squares are very important let me just
give up that rook wow wow what
understanding of this position i'm
saying great prep too because
i'm having trouble here so i can take
the rook you can i don't think there's
anything wrong with it
yeah that's what i'm trying to determine
uh what is wrong because i will always
have this move night on d2 to f1
whenever you know trouble bruise
uh brightly on the king side i've got
that great defensive move so bishop
takes bishop takes put it on the board
right let's check it let's check it out
we do have the analysis board on the
right bishop takes e5 bishop takes e5
looks forced to me you might as well
move the rook oh can you take one e and
d5 that was what i'm thinking too but
okay you
your first instinct is a good one
or maybe rook to d rook a2 no i like
rook c1 yeah and maybe i have to start
playing positional play something like
queen d6 and just harass your
uh position on the king side as well as
maybe tickling uh the pawn peter said no
no thank you palm takes d5 pawn takes d5
f4 i want to take your rook but not with
my bishop leave my bishop alone i love
it on b2 he's attacking the rook with
the f4 pawn does he does fabi have
choices he does have choices actually he
can go bishop g4 back he can put his
rook i don't think he'll put his rook on
h5 because i would capture your knight
on f6 which is the defender of the
knight on i'm sorry of the rogue
but then there is queen d boy this is
this is some
well we from what do we expect whenever
uh fabby sits down at the board he
brings
great ideas this is very exciting but
what about rook takes e4 rook takes c4
could also be playable i don't like my
compensation as much
when why not
because of the bishops i get to keep my
bishops in this line
you think so a move like queen d4 gets
your attention and
what you just said about keeping your
bishops that bishop on b2
is
good and for that reason fabi has played
the move bishop g4 it gives the rook
extra alternatives on where to move back
i don't think you can sacrifice this
queen so the queen does have to move
yeah because yeah you're you're thinking
about it but no no no no with the bishop
on b3 hanging i i could take on e5 with
the pawn and you know somehow take on f6
but unfortunately when the bishop takes
on d1 it's attacking the bishop so we're
expecting
queens queen c2 played queen c2 as well
as rook e8
on the board on the board
okay the game well it changed
dramatically it really has it's uh it's
so early but it's gone through
really uh metamorphosis here e5 screams
to be played right but then comes knight
h5 keeping up the tickling
uh then i agree the knight is offsides
on h5 but it does have purpose
threatening to take the pawn on f4 it's
surprisingly awkward to defend the spot
on f4 and it's vital to defend it
because it keeps your structure alive
yeah i mean your queen on c2 is not that
great if your queen could for example
magically go to e3 once knight gets to
h5 in order to defend pawn on f4 uh i'm
a fan i think i'll be a big fan of
white's position bus as it is right now
i like black's chances it feels like the
counter play is there and i really do
not want to play the move g3 here i feel
like i'm i'm leaving my king rather
vulnerable but on the other hand
i cannot allow bishop takes f4 bishop
takes f4 ruins my position
is white i don't like e takes d5 i do
he's played e5 knight h5 and f1 yes
i didn't like g3 but then again i love
the rook on e1 but okay you got to do
what you got to do and in this case
white absolutely had to defend the pawn
on f4
uh
peter down already to a minute forget
how fast blitz is a minute left here for
petersburg the move g6 was played i love
that movie i love that move too it gives
the f5 square to the bishop or to the
knight allowing it to retreat queen d3
played quickly by peter and there he
goes knight back to g7 he wants to
rejoin the fray with knight f5 for
knight e6 bobby saying you want that
button e6 you can have it there's a lot
of pin problems on that point and peter
says i don't care about you know
supposed tactics i want that pawn thank
you for uh for our the offer
the palm grabbers association loves it
vice president peter svidler right oh
and that's the tactic
bishop e6 that's a pin but guess what
94. oh that's a beautiful move that was
missed that was definitely miss you can
see favi thinking instantly instantly
missing the idea of knight f6 check
picking up whatever lands on d5 right
that cements the extra pawn for white
but more than that i think black's
position kind of collapsing the knight
has to retreat back to h5 it's all easy
uh traffic for white right
one defending the bishop on d5 extra
pawn
and
compensation i mean the d6 squares f6
squares are weak by the way g2 g4
lurking as a tactical
tactic uh you're not going to want to
take that on g4 because knight f6 check
and queen takes g6
uh this looks like a peter svidler
specialty he didn't become eight-time
champion of russia when uh not bringing
these kinds of positions home no this
looks amazing even with only a two
second increment this is very clearly in
white's favorite queen being played five
needs to do something active something
crazy and he needs to mix it up because
he's positionally lost and with he's
down upon so he really needs to do
something exactly we're expecting now
bishop takes e6 rook takes e6 now g3
and cementing that pawn and d7 because
that's what's going on bishop takes e6
on the board uh he has taken back with
the rook g3
cementing the pawn on f4
e7
yeah i was about to say i'm starting to
think of f5 and there it goes f5 blowing
up the king side only 30 seconds for
peters fiddler but he's in the offensive
initiative initiative and that move f5
is
a killer blow i'm sorry that i just got
i think that's it wow
f5 that's a great start here for peter
yeah i i i think this is over yeah the
move knight g7 i
i think that uh fabby's prep was
actually really really intriguing the
move knight g7 was simply uh a misfire
terror movement
whoa a little bit of a subtlety there i
don't know if it was necessary but peter
did good to put the knight on c5
i kind of like the rook on g6 i'm not
gonna lie i don't i i didn't understand
it myself i thought the knight was
heading for the f6 square right and uh
well we see a rook landing on f6 boom
and we're gonna deal with that not bad
i cannot take on e5 because rook takes
g6 pawn takes g6 followed by queen d5
check would pick up the bishop on e5 and
that's why we see an intermediate move
rook d8 i'm a little bit worried about
peter's time management down to 18
seconds but remember uh favi doesn't
have a lot himself 24 seconds for the
american player and a terrible position
now by trading on d1 he's what he's
missing
well he sacrificed an exchange basically
or lost it i'm not really sure bishop
takes e5 he had that trick still
available to him it's a full exchange
yasser uh
yeah yeah if you had to play bishop e5
then i'm sorry the position was gone
yeah
i'm not sure that fabi didn't just
simply miss
yet again this trick and by the way the
time is terrible for
queen e5 trying for some tricks maybe
knight takes g3 i don't know
queen f3 oh well yeah
we're just kidding peter 2.
uh that king is very exposed do i have
like bishop d4 here bishop before queen
e2 bishop i did not like queen f4
king f1 peter having everything under
control well is that true knight e3 king
queen h5 no g4
what about what's going on no it's
connected it's it's over right it's over
knight e6 and then you take the bishop i
think
check
just gaining some time and that is
checkmate i think queen d6 checkmate
petersville a huge win for him but karu
nakamura very happy with his draw he's
very happy with his draw not extending
his lead because he's still only one
point ahead of richard the report but
let's jump straight into the action
shakayama against
let's take a look at this on the 2d
board if we have it jack has an extra
piece for a pawn
sam is not going to make a fortress here
no no no way jose no that bishop on f3
defends all of the perpetual check ideas
you may have had
and
sam is just being dragged to his doom
i'm afraid oh yeah absolutely the
queen's gonna get to e5 at some point
and i think that's kind of it
right i was about to say uh you could
have played knight b7 there forced the
trade of queens
what
why did he
again will the real shakri are what is
shacriar doing bishop f3
oh that was his idea well i thought he
was going to go to e8 right oh oh oh oh
nasty okay you're just taking c7 right
all right
yeah and then you pick up the pawn
where's the easily going yeah i know you
can catch it
well that pawn went right
around the board and
around the board let's go around the
horn see what happened what results do
we have huge win there by peter svidler
shock
saying hey i need those gct points let
me beat sam shanklin honestly so making
a draw
voiceless making a draw in his game with
lanier over to your movies
well this round was crazy i mean i was
listening to you guys and following the
rest of the games as well there was just
some incredible moments in these games
this one between lee kuang lemon the
young jeffrey zhang it looked to be a
fight until he started getting outplayed
was jeffrey and then in this position
after knight h4 his pawn simply hanging
he didn't want to put his knight on the
h8 square so instead he played this move
knight to c3 but this
died quickly after knight g6 king he ate
and knight takes f5 and the whole
fleet collapsed and white went on to win
this game pretty easily in fact after
knight e5 knight b6 g6 and it's just
raining white pawns and that was all she
wrote in that position wesley so will be
kicking himself for a critical moment in
this game he played beautiful style at
least aggressive style it looked bad for
him for a while but i want to get to a
position
right
here right here in the game it seemed to
be a tough tight position and
down to the wire were both players with
seconds on the clock for lanier five
seconds left in this position he played
knight to e7 a terrible move queen d1
was better and after rook g5 after
knight at five what do you guys do
g6 um
you can hang out if you like look at
that check you can back up because the
queen's gonna show up and mate you in
the back row you'd have to give away
this rook immediately allow this
exchange and you're not gonna get
anything going because guess who's
coming back into the fray and you're
gonna get busted wesley miss rook takes
at five with a wow with much more time
on his clock than lanier an incredible
miss for a category player as wesley so
he's just not finding his true form here
in this tournament wow i would not have
guessed that rook takes that the bishop
on c7 that seems to be played right
right it's on the diagonal of the king
you're looking for those tactics always
you kind of say thank you right right
incredible wesley saw is so sharp he
usually sees this tactic
and well i mean i am being told well we
are the rapid and blitz in lewis
wrapping and blitz here if you want to
join us you can buy some merchandise
take a look at this beautiful shirt and
mask it is the one that sam shanklin is
using actually today so you can match
with the former us champion you can shop
at
qboutiquestl.com and also we have this
beautiful
what i'm
nice they really look good we do have
them in women and men versions and i
gotta say they're super comfortable they
look great they they look great i just
wanna
i just uh i like the style
the style is really nice they have this
like red outline it's really nice it's
modern yeah yeah yeah wow what around
hikaru not extending exactly his lead
but he's happy that fabiano lost that
game against peter for sure i think that
kind of that game that richard plays
richard does not make draws with white i
know he is like he's throwing
creative creativity all over the board
that really shows respect and let's take
a look at the standings after that first
round water blitz
12 and a half points total he is being
trailed by richard report with 11 and a
half favi with 11 and who is coming
there peter ziddler he has 10 points one
point away from fabi wesley wasting an
opportunity to put pressure there on the
leaders he has nine and a half points in
shock well well he's saying shaq says
well thank you i'll join sam and i'll
put some pressure on wesley to perform
and remember we of course have that
fight for first place but we also want
to see who is going to finish above
wesley so or shakira media who's going
to get those gct points exactly going
into the sing field cup and let's go to
the pairings for our next round again we
have nine rounds of blitz we just
completed our first round now we're
going to round two yes round two of the
blitz and guys what is the pairing that
we're going to take a look at we already
had it in the previous graphic is going
to be fabiano caruana again
laura a repeat of the final game of
round nine
well guys we're gonna take a small
breather we're gonna leave you with a
kasparov lesson all right and we are
going to be
right back with more blitz action
[Music]
[Music]
on and games are one of the toughest end
games to master because it requires very
precise calculation
and this one might really throw you off
because it's very unique but it
highlights the importance of opposition
and distant opposition that too
so here white black played the moving e7
and now we cannot just automatically
play any other move like ke2 or king f2
for example
we need to have a plan and the plan is
to somehow bring a king close to this
pawn on d6
and wherever we go we will be faced with
opposition
so let's say we play king to e2 he will
just play king g8 and wherever we try to
go he will just follow
and
this won't lead us to anywhere because
eventually we will be halted by black's
king
so we need to take a trickier route at
the beginning that's why after king e7
we play the
move king g2 the idea is that we try to
go
through this side
and we lower the king up so let's say he
plays king f6 to stop it
now we play the important move king to
f2 now securing the opposition
so wherever the king goes we take the
opposite roots let's say the king goes
to g6 then we go to e3
and then we play king d4 c5 or we can
bring the king
all the way
and if he goes back to e7
now we play king g3 trying to bring our
king again through this side which was
our original plan
let's say place king to f7 and now again
we play the move king f3 securing
distant opposition
it's important to note not to play a
move like king f4
which would
actually throw away all the advantage
because he can play king f6 and now he
has the opposition so wherever the king
goes he will try to follow it
and that's why it's important to play
king f3 secure the opposition first
now the king goes to e7 now we know the
standard way just bring the king
king g4
and now if he plays king f6 we again
playing f4 secure the opposition
if the king goes here
we run to this side to the left side and
if he goes to the left side we just
march in with our king to e6
or let's say he goes to e7 we play king
g6 and now he has no squares and the
king penetration is inevitable a
slightly tricky problem but nevertheless
very instructive
so black's move was king to a3
and the straightforward calculation
should make us understand that if we
simply go for king b7 king b4 king c7
king takes pawn king d7
he will play king d4 take the pawn on e4
and then e2 as well
so after king a3 we have to come up with
a new trick that is to play c5
king place comes to b4
we play c6
pawn takes c6 and now we play e5
and the only way to stop this pawn from
running is to play king c5 and here
comes the nice move e4 taking away the
d5 square for the king
so black is forced to move to b6 trying
to bring the king to c7 and now comes
the idea king b8 we secure the
opposition
again threatening to push the pawn on e6
black plays c5 we play e6 king to c6
again black's ideas to play king d6 and
block the pawn so we play the move e5
take away the d6 square
then black pushes the pawn on c4 and now
again the key idea to take the
opposition
because if you just push the pawn on e7
king will come to d7 and it's no good
so it's important to first secure king
c8 take the opposition
pawn comes to c3 e7 c2 e8 queen with a
check and on the next few moves we can
just come back with the queen and stop
the pawn on c2
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we are about to start the
second round of blitz of the day the
first one already brought us certainly a
lot of emotions as familiar carolina was
defeated by peter svidler and that means
that hikaru nakamura and richard report
gain a half point on him as they drew
the game against each other and for
richard that was a very nice result as
he is in clear second and fabby is now
looking
out
he's
he needs to come back and he needs to do
it now let's take a look at those
pairings round two of the blitz features
a huge game fabiano carrana with the
white pieces against hikaru nakamura
fabi wins we have him back in the race
naka wins forget about it
it could be over before it even gets
started and jeffrey zhang versus richard
will be our
backup game if you will if something
fizzles out baby game absolutely and for
the rest of the field i think svidler
dominguez still going to be an
interesting game spiller if he can move
two wins together to start the day that
would be amazing but for the gct
standings i wanted to say yes
a very crucial game in the gtc t
standings indeed as you get a look at
the players they're nervously waiting uh
for the clock to begin the way this is
going the way this is going 13 points to
nakamura if he wins this game
it'll be a big deal for the gct
standings however we're we may count out
bobby if he loses this game because he's
going to be so far behind naka he's
going to have a long road to go but
richard
is knocking on the door was richard
really wise in deciding to dock daca
right now like first with the white
people with the wife he said let me just
get this one out the way and face off
against everybody else because he didn't
want to lose tanaka that would have been
a disaster right he said let me
naka is he being strategic
because he does he have any real chances
to come back with the gct he only had
five points to you'd have to win it all
i think to get to 18
and
richard yes i mean it seems really hard
to imagine they didn't have to win the
singfield cup as well and hopefully
everybody
has disastrous events nevertheless if
you could come in the top two you know
come in second or third of the jesus
45k that's not bad that'd be a great
comeback that would be an amazing
comeback for him in fact so this game
though fabi man he just can't lose his
game and for richard uh
passed on the super bet tournament due
to illness nothing to do with govind uh
that would be remarkable uh to storm
back and take a second or third place in
the grand chess store uh
crazy crazy possible that would be
amazing to get to the top with one event
missing a classical event missing
right although this year they don't
that's true
right for every single one of the events
look at naka is he kind of semi-bored
like
by the way just notice
just just notice that they're not
there's not a face down going on it's
stare down i want to say the players
seem to be just looking be past one
another they're players who are friends
on the tour
i don't think this is buddy buddy yeah
mvl
you know they're two peas in a pod they
really admire one another this is a
rivalry well let's note when fabi came
back to the united states
uh from abroad he spent 10 years away
when he came back it was at a time when
naca was the number one player that's
true in the us
uh it basically naka's fortune started
to turn a bit as fobby showed up and
wesley showed up and so naca couldn't
have been too thrilled when fabi said
you know what i'm going back home i'm
going back home and i want to start
competing and i think robbie won the u.s
championship the first year he played
like came in and said boom i'm here
although he hasn't won one since
but still that was the beginning of the
turn for fernaka on u.s soil where he
was dominant he later won a u.s
championship though even post naka era
opposed to fabi era right but still to
have all those players show up
uh was not great for naka's fortunes
fabi's certainly one of those players
and fabian has since become the number
two player on the planet
and naka's become the number one
streamer chess streamer in the world so
their paths have diverged from that time
no question about it again we're
expecting the game to begin at any
moment
10 seconds away on
and again i just have to say that th
these chess tables are simply gorgeous
they look great on camera and the pieces
feel so good yeah these sets are
you can own a piece of history by
purchasing these sets and
handshake now you're going to fist bump
here we go let's see what fabi has
prepared again
who has been a little bit of a sitting
target with it yes and we've got the
rubinstein variation e3 on move four
right this was wesley's try against the
car not coming knight f3 by the way
a slightly different approach exactly
cd now hikaru has been saying i don't
mind playing the isolated queen pawn but
this time i think he will he's actually
giving the ice cream to fabi exactly
a2 a3 bishop e7 all one very very
standard tavia position right bishop
usually retreats to d6 or e7 and there
we go okay i think e7 was more popular
though and queen c2 is on tap you could
take on d5 and stabilize the position
both sides having an isolated pod but i
don't see that happening right and again
i just feel that
i'm not going to really say this is a
make or break game for fabby but
somebody's going to need to stop the
naca train
from leaving the station and
now would be a very good time
i would just play an all or no yeah make
a break game i think if he wants to win
this tournament he must win today
exactly and queen c2
uh tickling either h6 or g6 or something
he did not play that he played rookie
normal development very very very common
absolutely and now the thing is what do
you do with black because the desirable
move b6 just does not work right you can
take on d5 and it's not about giving an
isolated pawn the move queen c2 will
come with a double tickle exactly
um
here
it's funny i've always liked
to give my opponent uh hanging pawns as
well as isolated pawns knight takes c3 b
takes c3 it does help black pardon me
does help white with the isolated
quantum but knight c3 bc3 b6
is easier now for me to get in this
desirable move b7 b6 rook e8 keeping
everything flexible okay now this
is a big time move because i see queen
d3 queen h3 it's not very subtle but e3
will come in a diagonal we can make that
arrow to show what's gonna happen and
queen h4 it's actually hikaru who's
gonna turn aggressive on the king's side
first sometimes this queen ends up a
little bit misplaced on the king's side
but it does an important job offensively
putting pressure on the king side but
defensively as well as long as the queen
is on h5 it's very hard to put a real
attack on the h7 square
g2 g3 how do you like them apples i'm
not i'm not thrilled actually you know
g3
don't have to play that
exactly right right yeah no not a big
fan i still think you have to go queen
d3 though exchanging queens is not a
good idea when you have the ice hooded
pawn you have a structural weakness you
want to be as active as possible i'm
still kind of betting on queen d3 here
queen d3 again makes a lot of sense with
this battery
one of the things is that you don't
really
you don't want to trade queens queen g6
and i guess
knight e4 would make the most sense and
he's playing 94 immediately not he's
even waiting for the potential queen g6
94 the bishop of course
yeah there's this is that's clear that's
an easy one a knight two c three this
one okay offering a trade of queens i
don't think it's an offer i think it's a
you have to trade the queen well i i i
want to say uh a grateful offer
i'll accept the offer because that queen
sally queen h4
indeed was
aimed at like
we oops excuse me uh
tigran petrosian
was making a defensive combination
before you realized you had a chance to
attack
and that queen trade took a lot of the
energy the the attacking
uh energy that white has out of the
position so
i got to feel like hey if i'm black here
i've equalized yeah for sure and rook d8
is played black can even take the tempi
out to actually defend the knight on d5
you can recapture with the rook now and
keep that strategical pressure over the
pawn on d4 bishop g5 played pretty
standard a move it's not so comfortable
to defend the rook because you don't
want to play f6 but you do want to trade
pieces and then move bishop e7 on the
board exactly uh again when you're
playing against the isolated queen pond
essentially you want to get to a major
piece ending so any trades of minor
pieces tend to help the player who is
playing against
the isolated queen pawn now a big moment
actually knight takes d5 hiccaro has the
option exactly off taking with the pawn
making the position symmetrical there
would be this little detail that you
could argue the light squared bishop is
better for white because it attacks the
pawn on d5 but that is splitting hairs
exactly especially with the pawn on g3
he takes d5 the bishop will get to
develop to g4 with a gain of tempo
thanks to that whole queen h4
sally and but then again rook takes d5
bishop takes e7 and bishop b3 maybe
white gets to play the move d5
liquidating is it in time but i think
that if not maybe if even if that's the
case if that all you get is liquidation
i think icaru happily goes for it and
what he did hikaru do he do with the
pawn bishop takes e7 already on the
board knight takes knight t3 bishop e6
i don't think there's 24. i don't think
there's a real problem here for hikaru
i'd rather take white
yes it's pretty minimal well as you said
splitting hairs because
rook c8
king
is approaching and the king will set up
office on d6 controlling and protecting
this d5 pawn
no i see that this game unfortunately
for fabies fans
is going nowhere i'm expecting a draw
we'll
we'll keep an eye on the game of richard
rapport as our backup game yeah for now
let's keep this one up the move h5 blade
not exactly an aggressive move you're
just improving your structure into
future end games probably white usually
meets this with the move h4 himself and
yet when you play h4 then knight f5
yeah not so not so comfortable but the
the move h5 is so useful in rook and
pawn endings and
when you think about you know just
gaining some space and in this case i
like the fact that hikaru is carving out
some control over the f5 square he's not
just sitting there being passive and
saying you know we're going to chop off
all the rooks on the c file one day
but i like this move h5 a lot
okay we've got a little bit of a rover
and hikaru saying
is there an issue
along the b file and my first answer is
yes
rook c3 seems more or less and then i
will play rook c8
yeah it's a bit uncomfortable to keep my
rook on the third rank and it also means
that when you play rook c1 and we trade
rooks on c3 the bishop on b3 is
basically stuck it's tethered it's not
letting the b2 pawn get captured i'm a
little surprised by this movie knight c6
i was warming up to your idea of rook c8
because of the bishop and also because
his rook on deit is not doing anything
right but here hikaro has something very
clear in mind rook d2 knight a5 and
knight c4 let's take a look rookie can
you put that on your analysis yes a5
surely the bishop must retreat to a2 and
knight c4
and if i'm forced to give up my bishop
and why not
then this bishop and this rook yeah but
what do you do against the move knight
f4 here
oh i don't think you can defend the pawn
on c4
two minutes for both players remember it
is a blitz game and they have two
seconds
c8 but yeah yeah d5
okay uh
if if it was hikaru thinking that i can
afford to
mess
mix things up with knight c6 and knight
a5
um
i'm not entirely sure that's such a good
idea he's played the move rook d6 again
i don't feel like he's in real danger at
all but this is a bit unusual to say the
least and especially
when you've put your rook on b6 yeah now
i can go bishop a2 and i think he's
realized that this idea of knight a5 was
not very good because we do have the
moves knight f4 and immediately he
carver played knight e back to e7 okay
then we definitely had a hiccup but one
of the great things about these great
players when they make the slight
mistakes
they don't immediately commit for it
they say well
my position is still okay let me take it
back right one of the most difficult
things in chess for anybody including
top grand masters
is to recognize immediately you came up
with a bad idea
and to
take it back yeah but this is starting
to look a bit dangerous for hikaru king
f6 your rooks are kind of discordant can
i take on
e6
you would have to take with the rook
bishop d7 i don't know that bishop on d7
is pretty good actually can i take with
the no no you cannot take with the king
because rookie two rook takes e7 and can
i take the bishop alejandro you could
but knight c5 i think is just an 85 for
g5 yeah okay you're right okay i'm
taking with the pawn
i'm taking with the pawn now you're
going to go bishop e8 or
i might even still go bishop d7 and say
you don't have that many moves
okay i understand i'm not going to leave
this pawn
no pawn left behind but he played bishop
v8 actually immediately even before
capturing on e6 saying this guy who gets
the i want to kick this bishop this
bishop needs to go okay well uh and rook
dave played
i was about to say i just feel like
like fabby has eeked out something a
smidge
i don't think they'll feel it's gonna be
hard for him to do something
black species are a bit awkward but on
the other hand this bishop on a4 is
getting constantly hit tell me about the
clock it's 37 seconds for favi it's a
minute and 10 for hikaru finally no
interest in any kind of repetitions
hides the bishop back on a2 i actually
liked it on the diagonal it was but he
was unable to make any real progress
rook c5 certainly i i think there's no
doubt that favi is the one putting some
pressure but is it enough
somehow i'm looking for
i want my pieces on better squares so is
e5 a better square for my knight
is c5 a better square for my knight
dc2 being played do you the rook on d2
is not that
great do you capture this rook on c5 and
allow the take c5 i'm thinking knight f5
the knight of five blunders the d5 pawn
what it yeah it would have blundered the
pawn on d5
i think it doesn't deform it no it
didn't work well we'll take a look at it
later no no no no no no
the player it's hot and
hot
and furious going on right now we should
know that lanier dominguez and peter
spidler ended in a draw okay
peter svidler starting and then i there
going to f5 saying i'm posted up pretty
nicely forcing this defensive move 92. i
did think that playing b6 was a
concession because the c6 square is weak
not only for the rook but sometimes for
the bishop and there we go bishop on a6
bishop on b5 definitely advantage white
especially now with this bishop kind of
eyeballing this a6 square and
carlo didn't like that he he wants to be
able to meet the move bishop a6 with
rook a7
mission accomplished this bishop has
that i mean it really has right it's all
it's been all over the map oh i expected
the rook to land on c7
whenever the rook
moved away i don't think these trade
works i think you go to rook b3 i think
that was a big miss no that's a huge
miss in fact yeah this looks pretty
equal
not equal not completely equal but still
there was certainly more pressure with
the rook right well yeah g8 well king e7
knight f6 i wanted to say that black's
king is ideal on d6 yeah knight e7 what
what after g4 now there's there's a bit
of pressure here h500
night check wait what's going on whoa
whoa knight check bishop c2 chat no
no no that
what was knight h5 check wasn't that at
least a little bit awkward
for
definitely more awkward than this is
this looks completely fine for black
well especially when i'm looking at the
move f7 f5 and there it is f5
liquidating the position nothing to
discuss anymore everything just
got
vacuumed off the board yeah bishop c2
might even be played you could repeat if
you wanted to but
king f6 playing for a win
i'm not really sure why but playing for
a win here is hikaru
right on takes why i understand that
knight takes d5 check no nope
that was a very strange decision i must
say to play for a win there
remember there is no draw offer so even
if the players wanted to make a draw
they're going to have to find one that's
right repetition or a
total mass liquidation
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait uh uh
i was going to say uh
has he caro given
white
no there's not enough points there's not
enough points on the position this is
the last game remaining are we going to
wesley did win his game who's currently
watching it is inevitable yeah
everything's hanging yeah
meanwhile a huge result there for hikaru
rapport
lost his game to jeffrey strong jx in
the building and this draw means that
hikaru actually increases his lead a
little bit absolutely because his at
number two the player directly behind
him richard poor
losing uh
maurice uh do share some details with us
please
yes jx took care of business in this
game it was a nip and tuck affair and it
looked okay for richard but then he
messed up made some mistakes and this
none bigger than this one as you see
here this d-pawn is a problem he needs
to play the move king f6 right now and
get closer to that pawn instead he
played the move bishop to g7 thinking he
had a trick after d6 e4
opening up the diagonal d7 and rook c3 a
skewer hey maybe you'll come back
no you won't said jeffrey king d5 and
now the move rook takes on c7 he's
looking for d8 queens rook takes and he
gets a rook and bishop thinking that
might survive
not so fast knight e5 check
saving this piece because after bishop
takes then queens and how do you
maintain the defense of the rook and the
bishop simultaneously you're going down
here and he did uh rook f7 king takes e5
and the rest was a mop-up operation a
queen up so a big change in the
standings there also important for this
round was the game between chakriar and
wesley and there was a
critical moment in the game
sorry i picked up the lee kwang lim game
there it's this game i'm trying to pull
up here we go so this moment happened
when wesley played this move queen to b3
when everything looked fine for shakriar
and there's some
tactical ideas here that are fine
beginning with bishop f5 we won't go
into them but
knight c3 played bc3 played and now in
this position he needs to play a
remarkable move bishop to g4 this move
if you don't know the move in advance
you're not playing the line because it's
crazy ef6 bishop f3 would be possible
fg7 well that's the line that can be
played this is not the line i'm trying
to show either sorry it's after bishop
to g4 the move queen
takes on b7 goes into some wild tactics
after queen to d7 bishop to b5 and this
craziness could erupt on the board note
that this piece is defended the queen is
so you don't win material here because
of rook takes on b5 and black gets loads
of compensation in this line however
after
this move he did take on e5 and it was
simple for wesley i'll take one pawn
and like yasser would say
just take a pawn
thank you very much i'm too i'm just a
pawn up right away and wait a minute
you're gonna also go into an end game
let's trade it down so you have bad
pieces let's trade some more let's bring
my king to the center you're just down
upon for no reason right out of the
opening and he went on to win what a
gift for wesley easy peasy
but chakri are now
going down down down his chances in the
standings for the grand chess tour
overall as well
simply a terrible situation for him and
we can take a look at those standings
and right now look at that shakriar
down at nine wesley seoul on the rise at
ten and a half
knocking on the door is he
uh fabi happy to get a draw and he and
richard but man that number one standing
is saying a lot who picked not gonna win
this tournament that's what i want to
know
it's the hikaru nakamura show maurice
and maurice is
riding that horse to the finish nice
nice choice there and your pick he carl
looking regal amazing performance in the
rapid it's like he has had a full year
to just practice rapid and chat because
he's coming here and saying guess what
guys i'm the boss no matter how many
blacks i get you're not beating me not
only that the most the only undefeated
uh player in the tournament uh richard
rapport or second nick of pardon me fabi
uh both have lost a number of games
right uh especially fabi with that gift
against rapport that must have hurt
because remember had he won that game he
would be up there exactly but that's
gonna make a huge difference and let's
take a look at what we're gonna bring
you in our next round round number three
of blitz dominguez against caruana i
think fabi needs to score this i don't
care that he's black right he kind of
needs to go for it meanwhile hikaru
nakamura will be playing against jx
jeffrey shum who just defeated rapport i
think that would be our game to watch
meanwhile rapport himself will be
playing against sam shanklin mamadiarov
against fiddler and le quang liam in
that grudge match against wesley so i
remember they played the finals of the
chestable masters about a week ago
absolutely and we're gonna have another
quick casper of chess.com lesson for you
guys don't go anywhere enjoy this one
and on the other side of it we'll be
back with all of the action
[Music]
our first example is from a game from
the online nations cup playing with the
white pieces representing team india is
grand master pantala hari krishna and
with the black pieces grand master corey
george representing team rest of the
world
now it's clear when we look at the
position that white has managed to
create a lot of activity and has the
initiative and hari finds an impactful
way of making the most of black's
passivity in the position
he starts with the move queen 86 check
this has to be the first move that comes
to our mind it's a check it's a forcing
move
now the only two moves that makes sense
for for the blacks king is to g8 or to
h8 after king g8 spotting the move h5
which breaks open black's defenses
corey calculated queen g7 trying to
trade off the queens and the difference
with the king on g8
as opposed to the king on h8 is that
after h takes g6
black does not have the possibility to
trade queens because knight 886 is a
check the king would come to g7
picks up the bishop has to pick up the
knight and now the knockout rook takes
f6
is game over for black
hitting the rook on f8 with a check and
the eight seven pawn decides the game
so spotting this problem with the king
on g8 that knight eight six would be a
check
corey decided to play the move king to
h8 hoping for h5 so that then he could
go queen g7 and after hg6 he has the
time to pick up the queen because knight
886 is not a check anymore and now can
simply be met by bishop g6
but in chess every move has its own set
of consequences
what corey missed here was
tactics involving a pin the queen on 86
and the rook on f3 pin the f6 pawn
eyeing the rook on f8 the other tactical
motif in the position the queen on e7 is
overloaded it defends both the rook on
f8 as well as the rook on d7
spotting these different themes hari
krishna strikes with knight takes e5
a stunning move because black can
capture this knight in three different
ways but none of them work
queen e5 runs into queen f8 that's easy
to spot and after knight e5 if black
takes with the d-pawn white captures the
rook on d7 first
and wins the rook on f8 and the game
and if after knight e5
black makes the move f takes e5 and
using the pin white wins the rook on f8
also game over
let's move on to our next example and
this study really beautifully
demonstrates
how useful
the tactical motive of pin can be to win
a game now pin is one of the most common
tactical themes and in any game that
you're going to play in some form of or
the other it's going to appear on the
board the big question is always can you
make the most of it
a lot of tempting options come to mind
here one of them being the move rocket
shape because you spot that the bishop
on 87 is in fact trapped but black has a
really nice reply to this a
counter-attack with the move g5 hitting
the bishop on h4 and freeing the 8-7
bishop this would solve all black's
problems so rookie chet does not work
instead of rukich8 white finds another
forcing move starting with a threat on
the rook king to d1 hitting black's rook
on e2
now when you see the black king on d4
and the bishop on h4 we notice that they
are the same dark square color
a lot of squares are thus indirectly
covered by this bishop on h4
for example if after king d1
rook p2 is not possible because of
bishop f6 check a skewer picking up the
rook rookie 5 is not possible because of
the pin on f6 once again
so even though the rook on e2 is right
bang in the middle of the board it
really doesn't have as many squares when
you're trying to avoid a pin you have to
place your pieces in the opposite color
of the bishop
so black makes the move rook to e4 we
see that the black king is on the on a
black square while the rook is on the
light square so no pin is possible
currently
but unfortunately for black
white continues to insist with the move
f3
again
the e4 square is the absolute center of
the board but despite that the movement
of the rook is restricted
row cage 4 is met by rookie 4 check
again a skewer picking up the rook
rookie 5 is met by the pin
bishop f6
winning material rookie 3 also loses to
bishop f2 another pin picking up
material
so after the move f3
once again black does not have so many
options and has to move the rook to f4
now we have successfully placed the king
and the rook both on dark squares
which is the color of our bishop a big
red flag all we have to do is align
these two pieces so that we can pin and
win
and the way to do that we're a k4 check
a forcing line
black can't go to c5 or c3 as white
simply picks up the rook
king e5 is met by the move bishop g3
pinning the rook winning the rook
king e3 also loses to bishop g5 once
again picking up the rook
a very instructive study showing how
powerful the tactical theme of pin can
be when combined with a forcing sequence
of moves
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we're here at the saint
louis racquet and blitz about to start
the third round of the blitz portion i'm
grand master alejandra ramirez is here
with grandmaster yes sir sarah wanted
what a couple of rounds we've had so far
it's been very eventful indeed as we
take a look at our current standings
alejandro hikaru nakamura extending his
lead up to a point and a half over his
closer suitors faber karana and richard
report both of them drew against him
but fabi with the loss against fiddler
and rockport against with a loss against
jeffrey chong and hikaru looking regal
at the very very top wesley so had a
very important win i want to say over
shakuyar because of the grand
chess tour wesley's looking very good
now that he got past chat absolutely and
look at a blitz specialist there former
blitz world champion lee kuang lam has
started with the day with two out of two
let's see if we can continue that trend
but let's take a look at the pairings
and what interests us here in round
three i have my vote to be nakamura
against the young star jeffrey shong
absolutely
i agree
with victory yeah nothing nothing like a
victory to give you a little extra pep
uh richard reports sam shanklin also a
game that we should keep an eye on as
well as lanier dominguez uh versus
fabiano
absolutely meanwhile kuang lem against
wesley so we have a grudge match from
the chestable masters and we are recent
finals yeah the recent finals and we're
moments away about a minute away from
starting the third round you know i've
been wanting to ask you only in the
fourth day but you've come back from
sochi you had a lot of fun there you
felt that the organizers did a really
good job
organizing the world cup i think the
world cup was held in a fantastic
location we had access to all kinds of
restaurants overall i was very pleased
myself and we had a good time as far as
the environment around sochi was of
course it was always difficult with all
the kobe regulations that are going on
around the world the traveling is
currently difficult but the world cup it
was a blast for me and it was a blast
for a lot of these players who managed
to do really well remember that sam
shankland jeffrey shong they did really
well in the world
but duda candidate duda shall we say
candidate duda and candidates are gay
karjakin they earned their spots at the
world cup and they had extremely amazing
performance especially due to defeating
magnus carlsen and then going on to win
the finals and magnus himself uh pointed
out that duda had such an extraordinary
success that he didn't lose a game
uh in like it was like 13 he he pointed
out something that he that duda had
accomplished which really made it
obvious that dude
belongs as a candidate absolutely no a
very strong young player but speaking of
strong and young players it's america's
future jeffrey strong only 20 years of
age here
in his first grand chess tour event
ready to face off over the board over
the board because he did play on the uh
in the remote event but it wasn't a
grand chester event
st louis wrapped in blitz but it wasn't
a grand chester you're correct
absolutely and uh well both players
seem to be thinking like what will
trying to recall their homework i want
to say and there you go the clock has
started d2 d4 d5 will we be seeing
no queens can't be declined remember in
their rapid game jeffrey got a very
decent position
making a comeback
online yeah there's something about this
line that keeps coming back once in a
while it reaches its ugly head it's a
it's like fashion right it just kind of
uh goes back and forth basically white
could win a pawn there with knight or
queen takes the five butt and jeffrey no
doubt has that memorized down to the
teeth and nakamura wanted nothing to do
with that variation playing the more
positional and less ambitious line e3
saying you know what young man you can
have the opening bout i do not mind
playing equality i'm gonna outplay you
later
yes uh if you're not
like
really up to date with the latest and
greatest as far as queen takes d5 the
gambit is concerned
ducking
is not a bad choice
we should point out by the way that
there are two players on
diverse ends of the spectrum at the
moment sam shanklin lost his first two
games oh
that's bad for him considering that he
had such great games earlier in the
event right lee kuan lim has won his
first two games the only player in the
field who's done that so far so watch
out because he's a blitz specialist as
well so he could start making some noise
but they're going in opposite directions
yeah tale of
two cities there let's take a look at
everybody carl's doing bishop d2 i feel
is a pretty strong concession in this
kind of position why because you give up
a bishop you mean just simply knight
takes d2 queen takes d2
uh
again whenever we're we're trading uh
we're playing against the isolated queen
pawn i want to see traits of minor
pieces so why do you think knight takes
d2 queen takes d2 is that big a deal
it's not a huge deal but i think it's a
minor concession in the sense that you
give up the bishops
yes in the sense you're not taking this
night under any circumstances i'm
assuming you're playing bishop e6
castles castles and we just get along
with business i still think pretty much
equality in that position the question i
had though is a similar idea different
approach as
do i
should i trade bishop takes c3 and try
to split your pawns i think that's also
a possible scenario but i had talked
about earlier that hikaru tends to love
these structures where you split the a
and b pawns you take on c3 and you're
fighting against an isolated pawn on d5
hicaro has basically made a living
winning these kind of strategical
positions okay
so that's why you not anticipating
bishop takes c3 by jeffrey and did
jeffrey come up with a
g4
a third
alternative bishop g4
all right he's kind of waiting for white
castle question is what happens on
knight takes e4 knight takes e4 dt d5
takes e4 no real problems there the
bishop on b4 is defended by the knight
on c6 that is true but for the moment
point
i am considering bishop takes b4 pawn
takes because i can't play
knight takes b4 because there is queen
a4 check
i have to make i have to avoid this
there's a a trap in the position
that if the knight retreats the pawn on
e4
is captured so bishop i don't know
bishop g4 might
yeah what is the idea because wrong
knight takes e4 pawn takes e4 bishop
takes b4 pawn takes f3
can i take on f3 g2 yes
i actually even like playing queen takes
d8 as well but i absolutely but do
believe that i can win a pawn
castle
and it said yes a pawn win was there
knight takes e4 correct
by the players they're unusual that we
see more than them we're going to take
away uh
the membership card of
icarus club castles but i didn't like
that move bishop g4 in general it it
felt like a hiccup kind of castles by
by jeffrey
now the
the moment has passed knight takes e4 d5
takes e4 bishop takes b4 knight takes b4
there is no queen a4 check anymore
black's perfectly fine i think black is
a [ __ ] in this position right
yes he has so much development he does
have that strategical problem with the
isolated pawn that's more or less
permanent but look at white's pieces
really not putting that much pressure
and by the way bishop d2 to e1 we talked
about old-school chess when we were in
the rapids and
the old guys would put their bishop on
e1 and e8 but usually they kind of
brought the rook out first
so
bishop d2 the e1 doesn't really inspire
confidence having said that
he hikaru is trying to get jeffrey into
playing that pawn structure that you
mentioned the split pawns a2 c3 versus
the pawn on d5 i would have
automatically recaptured with the bishop
i did not like burying my
one
i must confess i think you're absolutely
right bishop takes c3
would have been played by myself in an
instant b2 takes c3 i'm warming up to
white's position because of the bishop
on e1 i'm thinking you go knight e5
knight c4 you control the light squares
say what say what say what knight d4
there was a trade of light square
bishops yeah
by the way
wesley so mixed something up in the
opening and it's dead lost after just 17
moves
against lee kuang lim we said he was on
fire wesley so something in his opening
to newark and now he is getting
rolled he's in huge trouble in his game
that's really extraordinary because
wesley
has had
such a great
year in terms of solidity his openings
have been great if it's going to be
three out of three from la cuando yeah
i'm starting to get perugia
i'm telling you liam uh dead last as he
started today's action bit like ferugia
was in that tournament where he scored a
huge amount of points in the blitz
portion yeah well
liam is a former world bliss chess
champion
and he's
he's regaling us with some of the form
that made him world champion by the way
f3 knight f6 bishop h4
i would have been very reluctant to play
the move knight f6 i thought knight c5
was the intention nope
knight f6 was played bishop h4 rook e8
and we're caught up with the players
on our analysis board
is that pin
knight f4 and we're about to find out if
there are some problems for black in
this position rook takes e3 it runs into
bishop takes f6 knight takes d5 with a
double attack so hikaru is certainly
trying to expand and jx said i don't
care yeah rook takes e3 i'll take with
the pawn
yes and that's what he's done but
boy those double pawns on the king side
will they come back to haunt
jeffrey on the other hand he is pretty
active and that pawn on c3 that's the
big weakness knight takes d5 i expect to
move rook e5 to play it very quickly yes
or very quickly very very very very very
quickly wow maybe he doesn't like maybe
maybe rookie six no rookie five played
it seemed like the normal place for the
rook same move
faster was better
yeah jeffrey with a minute and 20 and he
carl with two minutes on the clock to
move c4 on the board knight a5 they said
give me that phone but wait a minute
there's queen g4 check yesterday you're
saying that jeffrey's trying to get into
the pawn robbers club too early
yeah he could be he could be but okay
i'm looking at quincy for check and
where am i going to put the king h right
on h8 okay and uh no rovers
rook
f3 knight c4 rook g3
uh i haven't come to a conclusion it's
tough and high has a mid of 32 figure it
out queen g
queen g4 check did get played right no
queen h5 actually was the move that
hikaru chose not giving the check not
scaring the king away no surprise they
didn't interpose them of queen g4 but
jx said give me that pawn
his direct approach to the position so
jeffrey with an extra pawn but clearly
the weakness of the king side is going
to be plenty of compensation rook f3 was
played as we're being told that wesley
actually ended up miraculously saving
that game a draw a big one for wesley so
as we see hikaru on the hunt against
this young man jeffrey shong exactly
those double pawns are beginning to
haunt a little bit
and again uh if you don't mind telling
me the time 40 seconds for jeff three
about there 40 seconds now
95 what a move okay knight wants to
retreat to g6 and defend everything and
currently the knight on d5 there is this
hanging there is rook h3 check
g3 check you mean g6 no pardon me rook
h3 i was thinking uh was the problem
with knight e5 and hikaru instantly
played rook g3 i think there was some
opportunity there with rook h3
uh at once but
we do have rook h3 now on the board what
was 95 rook h3 i don't know it was fine
for black it was okay all right let's
take a look because i saw c8 was hanging
on h6 oh there's no mate on h8 i'm just
confident
boss what a move by jeffrey zhang wow f5
doesn't work i assume rookie five no
no rookie five yes yes sorry yes
well queen d5 in this queen d4 check you
may be right f5 queen takes d5 looks
like a refutation to the move f5 yeah do
we have to play knight e3 and maybe red
maybe back down 93 queen d4 starts
looking awful i think you play rook d1
you put that rook oh rook d3 looks like
a bit of a concession rook d6 instantly
played by jeffrey equalizing time pretty
much remember they have a two second
increment 27 seconds for jeffrey thirty
one for sixty five rook c five along the
pressure one yeah
there's this pins all over the place
uh
the rook on c5
will be hitting oh that's a lot of time
say move faster remember queen f3 look
how hikaru instantly replies king g7 or
gf8 he moves out of the checks i was
thinking kenji but king f8 looks like a
solid decision as well the kid's so calm
i know he's a little too common like for
him yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah feeling
between four
guys
once i don't want to take that no and
instantly knight e7 that's what he's
talking about he has to take on e7 i
take on d3 now start simplifying the
position right there right right t3 rook
d3 why is he he's seven he has to take
on d3 you've got three seconds left i
play faster you're squeezing take me out
to play queens
what are you doing what what are you
doing
he flagged he flagged what he just let
his time run out he was hesitating too
much no he was lost at the final
position i think because queen takes e7
q8
check check and rook g3 oh that was
probably a blunder right by john and
jeffrey
uh let's look at rapport i'm currently
in second position playing against sam
shanklin let's try to get the 2d board
so we see what's happening
uh a little up
up up up up up up more and more yeah
thank you
yeah but we don't understand the
position so let's take a look at the 2d
board so that we can see what's
happening
[Music]
f8 had to be played
sam shanklin missed a huge two seconds
though
oh
he's uh he's at increment mode he's got
to play quickly queen b7 what
is going on here is the seventh rank
queen
oh no perpetual for you
still trying to trick him somehow
rook d7 now queen cied is very dangerous
queen d7 played in shaq queenie six
he's decided to go for this position
richard saying
sam yeah wow but he has some winning
chances in the sand game right though
yes he does
yes seriously coupons in the night is
very sufficient compensation when
everything is on one side of the board
but that was huge move rook d2
that will
that will nail the the draw i think
right you can give a perpetual but you
cannot actually defend the f2 pawn right
as richard yeah a draw agreed there
richard rapport bobby meanwhile let's
take a look at what's happening this
looks like a dead draw i don't think you
win with an extra one pawn right no
i've seen weirder things in this
tournament but this one looks pretty
over
exactly yeah knight d8 knight f7 oh
you've got to take on g5 yes draw there
by fabinho karana draw also by richard
report but guys that's not enough hikaru
nakamura won his game keeps extending
the lead hikaru the monster
yeah the hikaru nakamura train is going
at full speed but let's see that jeffrey
zhang
97 was a blunder he realized it here and
he flagged after rook takes d3 because
he has no other move he
failed to realize that after rook takes
d3 queen takes e7 queen a8 check would
come as a devastating move so he flags
him in a completely lost position
against icaru 97 just no good he
basically tricked himself he did he did
wow he was encouraged to transact or get
bluff
in this moment right here when he played
the move h4 hikaru just kind of tossed
it out right you know i can do this and
all the youngsters have to do is say
well what if i just take it like got it
he no doubt saw this move and got
spooked by it what do you do given that
your h pawn is a and your knight is
hanging but there is the sweet move king
g7 you're not the only one who's got
knights hanging this one is hanging
right here as well and the kid's fine
just perfectly fine if he had found just
take the pawn and defend that's it naka
would not have had any edge whatsoever
matter of fact just gave up a second
pawn he'd be down two pawns with no
attack the knights coming back to g6
against any checks no worries for him
here he missed this with very few
seconds left on his clock speaking of
missed moves we had one game between
and wesley so wesley was so dead in the
opening i mean dead dead with a capital
d
uh right let's go back to the moment
right here
look at this position this this knight
oh i want to go back further because the
game was so ridiculous what happened in
wesley he allowed this position to occur
on the board d4 with his knight on f8
timing was terrible bishop to e6 queen
to e2 he takes the knight takes look at
these knights just pick him as you want
to he traded here brought a rook to the
middle of the board
and this knight dance he's an f4 like
just let me go here i come bishop d7
knight f5 very smartly done and now we
get to the position where he didn't want
to bring his knight back once more and
this e5 is going to open notice you
can't castle easily because the bishop
is hitting the a7 square he played
knight h4 and this is where
tantalizing move just want to play it
you just want to play he played queen h5
check
in this position queen h5 not the best
move though it was still winning after
knight h4 the best move was to just keep
piling on the pressure here with this
one if you dare to castle in the
position now queen g4 and
hand your knight over right just hand it
over and if you don't castle after rook
to e1 decided to take this pawn this was
the subtle win guys queen to d3 yeah and
it says here we come
this is not going to be any fun for you
there's some lines we could look at like
queen d7 bishop c5 discover check don't
block with the knight d6 is hanging if
you hide this piece we're going after
yummy with this knight you're pinned
here and if the knight leaves move the
queen out of the way and here comes the
rook and the whole party is going to be
at your house that was not what he
played like we said he played queen h5
check and then g6 this bishop on e3 is
hanging with check so you don't get the
knight right away he took allowed this
king h1 and guess who ran out of the
middle as fast as he could because he
said i'm out of here go for it now g7
he's still better here but then he got
greedy and took this pawn and that
allowed boom wesley to sack back
now of course this rook is coming in
maybe you get made it right be careful
queen five check king b8 king g2 rook to
ga check king h1 and then
bam wesley so with the defensive tactics
and there's no win anymore after this
check you gotta block give me that and
wesley saved the day with a per pet and
went on to draw amazing turn of events
wesley hanging on by his fingernails in
that one liquor on him missing a golden
opportunity but the story is is the
tournament over looks like
nakamura is just too dominant hikaru
nakamura train is choo chooing along
we've seen greater comebacks than two
points even coming into the last day
remember mvl making it up but that was
mvl which one of these players is such a
specialist that's gonna make up a huge
difference already even with so many
rounds to go pay attention to peter
svidler two and a half out of three he's
getting started he's feeling the group
he's feeling the groove he's had a good
day and he karo nakamura ruining the gct
points for the grand chester remember
mvl is watching on the silence he's here
in st louis watching this tournament
he's cheering he's cheering god
absolutely go wild card players go take
as many gct points as you want take them
home with you yeah wesley seoul not
bringing home the bacon he's not
that typical of fighting for the lead
wesley but i gotta tell you that was a
beautiful defensive road
you feel like you swindled the victory
out of that position there are some
draws that just feel sweeter than a win
i know that was one of them a nice catch
maurice i love that i didn't do anything
that's the juicy stuff that
wesley needs to stay
close he needs to just stay right there
because
he could get
six or seven points out of this he needs
to salvage some points i don't think
he's getting eight because eight is
clear third right you get 13 for first
naca looks like he wants to steal that
and then 10. for first 13 12 yep first
knuckle looks like he's taking he's
taking the 13. yeah yeah yeah yeah but
but let's say so yeah locker looks like
he's taking that then the next is ten
points a big drop who takes second place
there
and then the next is eight eight now
okay clear third clear third that's a
lot of points wesley somehow sneak seven
or six
if he gets that he goes all the way up
to 28.3
and makes a big statement against maxine
maxine you better win the sink field cup
right and hope that i bomb in the same
field
if you're going to win this whole thing
well something that maxime has done
before a previous winner of the single
field cup beating nepo in the last round
in a must-win
situation you know what you know what
though the way this is going the way
it's shaking out yeah with chakri are
fading
maximize thinking you guys are dumb even
if wesley wins the whole thing i could
come in second and pocket 50k
after what wasn't the greatest start
he started horribly in this whole thing
he bombed in bucharest right i believe
it was right to come back and block it
50 k in the pocket
that's not bad either he's right smiling
either way let's take a look at the
pairings for the next round
absolutely here you go yasser we got
fabi caruana against jx jeffrey shang
can fabi win a game today i don't think
he's won a game today right yeah but i
like that wesley so versus richard
rapport game lots of points between
those two players as they get ready for
battle i think that might be our marquee
match we also do have former us champion
sam shanklin against karnakamura but sam
not exactly a blitz specialist he did
save the game against richard rapport we
got lots of blitz
left today folks we have nine rounds of
blitz today and tomorrow but we're gonna
take a break we'll be right back with
round four don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the hikara nakamura show
i mean that's rapid and blitz as he is
unstoppable right now extending his lead
game by game let's take a look at this
lead he has a two-point lead over the
field fabinho karan and richard report
are still tied for second chasing him
but it's not as close as it used to be
it's another point that hikaru has added
on them it's the two-point lead hikaru
uh sorry fabian richard with 12. wesley
saw two points out of three he is
currently well with 11 and peters
fiddler well he's had a pretty decent
day one and a half points 10 and a half
score liam with two and a half and our
pairings as we get ready for the duels
for round four absolutely fabiano carona
against jeffrey sean that is going to be
a traditional duel at the u.s
championships fighting for relations but
here they need to score but i think that
we're going to pay attention to that
game wesley so with 11 points against
richard rawford that's going to be
exciting i absolutely agree we will keep
an eye on shanklin versus nakamura as
well as but we don't want it to turn
into the hirokara nakamura show we want
to see a lot of these competitors
because
they are and off we go e4 e5 wesley
we've seen a lot of italian in this
tournament no exception
bishop b5 and this seems to be like a
wesley specialty i want to say and the
weird thing is that he placed it with
white and with black
right yeah yeah isn't that
rather remarkable uh
where did shaq go wrong because
essentially he was busted he didn't he
played something with f6 and not h6
right h is a completely different
approach uh here by richard report was
he hesitating a little bit but deciding
you know what i'm just going to stick to
my principles classically castles and
now comes the move bishop g4
right
okay i always like to get in the move h2
h3 i felt i was making luft
in such cases and then i would play
bishop e2 but
will yeah well he was reaching
again another has
that looked like prep knight takes steve
what's going on if i take the bishop on
g4 knight takes c3 and the bishop on b5
is hanging what if i take the knight on
d4
with the bishop then you take on bishop
on f3
whoa whoa whoa what's going on he's
asking the same questions that we're
asking ourselves
whoa what if i take you to the bottom
actually
can i take with the pawn is that too
much queen g5 coming and i guess my king
is too exposed
i'm worried that it would be a
repetition right out of the gate
just what you said uh in case wesley
captures
with the pawn it's this move queen g5
check that's upsetting
king h1 we'll go queen h4 king h2 we'll
go queen f4 i don't know if i go queen
f4 i'm going to play knight g5 yasser
you're ready
i don't want your thinking
give me a full point there knight g5
just crushes queen takes h3 and knight
takes f3 you are
stone cold right oh yeah and let's take
a look what happens if queen takes f3
just just take back on d4 right yes
very very happily so and i've regained
my piece and
no no no problem no but i have that
bonus block actually right right i i
will have to take on e4 pawn takes e4
queen takes e4 bishop takes b2
rook b1 gift
oh i'm going to play bishop d3 you know
what i'm going to i'm going to threaten
a mate first and only after g6 will i
play rook b1 because i didn't want to i
didn't want to face queen d4 when the
bishop was on b5 right i wanted to open
up the b file but okay queen d4 in that
position though right yeah but then i'll
make a draw after oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
well i think buck's trying to win this
well they played they're playing the
whole line they're playing the whole lot
the whole thing we predicted look at us
not too shabby okay all right uh g6
already on the board i don't think
richard has not fallen below the five
windows that he started with it's total
preparation whole preparation excellent
and completely shutting down this line
rook 81 not being played just yet he
does have the option of maybe playing e6
maybe playing the move rook 81 i don't
think he could be set for bishop c4
bishop c4 could be also tickling g6 uh
pawn after bishop c4 kind of provoked
king g7 rook d1
i feel
maybe i could play for the initiative i
feel white has compensation but i cannot
imagine it's enough to anything more
than yeah just equality just equality
right okay so in that case we'll be
juana's problem well well he played he
played what played
he made a hand gesture that i did bishop
c4 okay he didn't follow your advice
bishop c4 going a bit for the initiative
queen g6 is a very big threat in this
position you definitely have to prevent
it i have at least a perpetual
probably that's all i have but
yeah bishop a1 queen g6 king h8 queen h6
king g8
and if i take on a1 simply maybe queen
d4
rook queen g5 check and then rook c1 i
think i would just do it yeah you're
right yeah why not why not keep playing
right i don't think there's no risk yeah
riskless completely i expect this g6
pawn to be defended i think we do have
rook on a1 on b1 on the board though oh
i apologize that's my analysis right so
we're still waiting there for uh
richard's decision is the first time he
thinks in the game right probably
getting
a little bit c4 uh yeah accustomed to
the position seeing what's going on
straight out of preparation
a full minute thing that is a huge
amount for a blitz game yeah that's like
what 20 of your time uh
being uh evaporating if you will very
good and we do have some moves
king g7 played and quickly rook the one
following your advice there for the
initiative well
it's been the case and we've seen it
time after time in the rapid how
important
holding the initiative is and that's
what we're talking about e6 repairing
ideas of rook d7
and queen b7 if you take on e6 queen b7
and well the structure is a bit of a
wreck it is on the other hand it is an
extra pawn still for the black side
i will never argue against the extra
bonds never never never well
yeah
yeah yeah that was saying
never say never pawn takes c6 on the
board i do like the move queen takes b7
and there it goes it wrecks the
structure and attacks the bishop on b2
not a big fan of bishop take c6 type on
e6 is a weakness just leave it there
take the healthy one right
rook oops king g7
let me just catch up with the player so
i'm just going to go back and forth i
apologize
no problem there as richard report is
taking his sweet time i think in a blitz
game i take white every single day but
it really isn't a serious advantage
no the uh
the bishops of opposite color i
i constantly say the same thing in the
bishops of opposite color end game one
of the things that really stands out is
the vulnerability of the king
and in this case
white has great compensation because of
this vulnerable king on g7 yeah but
richard
hey check it out i have threats too
five threatening queen takes have to
check i don't think i'm actually
throwing the bishop on c4 because i do
have to watch out for this bishop on e5
on a story rook descent i think he's
saying he's not going to care just king
h
weenie iv queen f2
king h1 no i can't take on g6 what am i
saying
g6
e1 rook is hanging yeah exchange side
guys
rook takes e5
let's do it
rook d7 played and king h8 you're saying
rookie takes e5 queen takes e5 and rook
takes
c7
but that's just the drafter queenie one
i guess perpetual check on e1
and
five squares right but that might be the
right right way to bail out if i'm
wesley and he played that gorgeous
defensive combination in the previous
game yeah yeah by the way is it a draw
rookie 5 queen f2 now
yeah but king h
i don't think it changes very much
actually king h1
oh it does it changes everything you
don't have a clean f4
my bad and he has gone for it under a
minute is wesley so rook takes e5 on the
board queen takes e5 we expect the move
rook takes c7 and played play what's
your actual threat rook h
seven and bishop e6 that's right
checkmate so you're saying that right
yeah
so you noel the
not so random move would be rook on a8
allowing you to go check in this case
because i put my rook on e8 i mean i'm
defending against bishop takes e6 and we
have two a couple checks there by
richard he can if he wants to keep
repeating the position wesley has no
capacity to block avoid
the repetition right the question is is
there anything else for block here rook
on a8
[Music]
a winning attempt by richard he is after
all an exchange up remember every
winning attempt is also a losing attempt
whether you have a king on a chain being
hunted by those major pieces in the
seventh rank
no you have to be very very courageous
indeed not to make the repetition as the
players do shake hands let's go to our
alternative games we've got sam
shankland as well as peter svidler where
would you like to go let's go to the
samshackle against hikaru nakamura game
duel of us champions one is uh the both
of the former u.s champions ricardo
many times and shanklin i went three
times
u.s champion uh i was the first uh by
the way to congratulate ikaru because i
had four he had five i thought you were
gonna say you're the first u.s champion
in history no
to congratulate uh hikaru for passing me
i thought that was very very good of him
um of course bobby fisher has the record
and
walter sean brown what is going on let's
take a stock sam shanklin 41 seconds
against chicago's minute and 30 but i'd
like sam's position are you sure
hikaru's got this huge move knight d3
yeah but 93.
about to play knight d3 and rooksy to
check
is he karu this bishop on f4 is also i
was about to say the rook on d6 also
vulnerable because it relies upon the
protection of the bishop on f4
uh
i like
icaru's position here rook czech and
rook c8 i kind of like the fact that i'm
playing with all of my pieces though
precisely rook c2 no i mean like white
is and black isn't
well what
i don't think i don't see this but
that's the biggest problem there
sam
13 seconds against cicaro's minute yeah
that knight takes me seven
oh and he's going for me he's going for
mate
he hasn't sacrificed he doesn't have two
pawns though
um well he goes about that two
that little twist by hikaru
with uh bishop to
and i think he's going to pick up f2
right oh no knight d6 94 is going to
come oh and there was the shake of the
head by hikaru well rook takes b2 when
you want to take a pawn yeah it's not so
clear though after knight d6 and then
knight coming back to i don't know if f5
or e4 f5 so rook b2 knight takes d6
knight d6 check king f8 knight f8 knight
five f
six to avoid back ranked mates maybe
rook b8 should still be better for
icarus back to d6 anyway right yes
g6
well can i defend that bond with b4 whoa
he gave it away why carl a little
puzzled there that he's like thank you
for the pawn why didn't he play bf b3 or
b4 we don't have time to analyze it
unfortunately rook c3 threatening i
guess rook c7 is an actual threat in
this position
not the easiest conversion for hikaru
but that time advantage that's going to
be huge in this position he's so
dangerous i feel that the rook on g1
looks good but does nothing i think it's
time to bring that rook to the a file i
don't even think it looks good
and i did not quite understand h4 giving
the rook an idea sam's playing a bit too
slow for my taste h5 making another
weakness well but he is hoping for
knight g3 and knight f5 i think that
knight on f5 would be an extremely
useful and there he goes and he's there
he goes
e5 can you play it though gosh he
carries he he senses
f5 check is automatic for me take on h6
can you take on h6
maybe not maybe that engine was just bad
but quite possibly
he didn't give it too much of a
consideration e3 e4
knights love defend to being defended
e3 e4 you're going to get h5 but i'm
gonna get a7
maybe not
are you sure about that a7 i'm sure
about h5 h5 is very good connor and
that's an exchange for hikaru i still
think
you said the conversion's going to be
difficult but it's coming
but it's coming king b5 and oh i was
about to say king e5 no
and now i feel like
is in the driver's seat big time big
winning
position here for hikaru threatening
rook b5 check 94 to stop rook b5 that
icaro time again
what 11 seconds each
each yes so hikaru has
also let
things slip oh what a move h5
that was gorgeous now he's going to use
using his h-pawn as a decoy is hikaru
and he's one apiece
now that's over that's it
with another win black pieces against
sam shackling who is going to stop this
man wow and let's quickly switch to
uh the game between uh
fabi and
jeffrey oh let's take a look at the 2d
board if we can for a second because we
do not know what's going on
it's over oh it's over it's over what
does it mean it's over what happened
here
but who won that game
i think
fabby lost
did he
uh
yeah well let's take a look at this
fabby lost with the white pieces against
jeffrey okay
and this is a
beer flagged
peter flag
no i don't think i can't imagine that
that black lost
what can we get a replay of that song
white lost
that did why lose that position yeah
maybe he did crazy there is knight d3
in knight c5 maybe he did walk into a
zug slug no and this is not a zugzwung
but he just flagged but he did fly he
flagged oh my goodness so that was a
pretty bloody round there was a roller
coaster only one draw between the wesley
saw and richard rapport that we looked
at lots of points got uh spewed over the
board tributed dominguez beating
mamedyarov is their duel my match has
nowhere to be found
fading badly
you don't want to know how badly yeah
this game right here between lanier and
chatriar
lanier was all over him if we go back a
couple of moves you'll see what i'm
talking about this is petrol uh right
sure looks like look take a look at
right here
bishop takes on gc after queen c5 he
said uh uh give me scrumptious hello
give me that
how could you survive this position if
you are black like this is over right
like this is over soon
you don't know the half of it give me
that i'm just gonna shift
your your king is just
open completely uh alejandro said five
pawns up i i'll give you five puns just
let me have a king like this to attack
please rookie eight rook h1 it's all
sweet rookie six queen h8 king of some
queen c8
d5 and now the killing blow just drop
your rook the party on h8 another rook's
gonna show up on f1 it's going to be all
she wrote this is over this is me
uh started with a check
still winning started with this check
why not bring something to the back row
well
king d7 and all of a sudden
because both of them were in terrific
time pressure plays this move a3 and now
rook g2
you could still attack and win
he took a pawn like change the game he
is winning the position still but not
after this move made it much more
difficult for him and now they're
blitzing out they were down to seconds
each tray trade
brook takes g1 queen of two and now this
move allowing rookie one and all of a
sudden you're only up one pawn and this
is no longer winning this is fine for
black unless he plays this sequence
and commits suicide like what did you do
this for exchanging queens onto a k pawn
end game like why did you do this to
yourself and a few moves later
after this he tried to play and here
comes
the pieces check king here king d4 and
the king is going to penetrate and break
down your position
unbelievable result for shakira losing
this game now that's horrible yes wanna
see something else that's horrible how
did fabi lose this game he was hunting
his opponent the whole way
and this pawn of course racing down the
board a8 queens rook takes and we're
taught get your rook behind the pass
pawn he had to take in this position
with the king
king take saves the game anything like
this he can start checking rook to a3
king to e4 now bring the rook down and
technically i can go through this whole
thing the engine is giving a draw for
white for white here because of the rook
being behind here but he took with the
rook in this position and let the pawn
go immediately now the pawn is just too
fast rook f8 king to e3 rookie 8 king f3
king c6 there goes one there goes
another they're just too quick king to
d4 and now he resigned because d2 and
you're not catching these bad boys
there's just too many of them and
one too many and that's it fabi loss to
jeffrey young fabi is fading
fast he was the leader the leader in the
event coming in to uh to well he was in
second sorry coming into today there was
a time when he was leading clear but
ever since that loss to nakamura fabi
has been slipping and slipping he at
least is holding on by his fingernails
to third place at the moment but there's
wesley right behind
can wesley overtake him and get some
points for the grand chester i'm sure
maxine is shaking his head going come on
what is this fabi win some games what
are you doing he's going to get one
point out of four today it's pretty bad
hikaru and liam are really showing their
class
very good and three and a half out of
four for liam how did liam win that game
well let's take a look through the magic
of television
let's focus on the clock there
there's a little bit of hesitation
remember he did the same thing against
what is he doing you can't just oh
more than four seconds
no
oh my god and you know the second time
he did it in the tournament he did it
against
shaq and it
it's really really costly very costly
there for peters fiddler painful wolf
but 12 and a half points being second
place hikar has 15. right i'm telling
you and uh
he's
and we are going to take just a very
quick break here but we're going to
leave you with an interview about how
the players dealt with their time off
the boards yeah how do you stay in shape
the pandemic has affected everyone how
did it impact you and have you done
anything special during this pandemic
new hobbies did you read study right
what have you done
one of the good things was that i
got to spend more time with my with my
family so i have a six-year-old boy and
it was great normally i'm
away from home like half half of the
year or something like that yeah i pick
up a lot of new openings i learn a lot
of new stuff and i try
in my online games this break has done
me a lot of good
it's definitely given me some more time
to think about how many careers doing
chess wise
also
during the break and due cancellation
major tournaments last year i was able
to have time to write a book make some
video video courses it was pretty huge
work
something that a lot of people have been
doing already by that point but
something that i only really started
doing seriously in 2020 was streaming
which did uh i think a lot of good for
my like general well-being more than
anything else yeah i mean i think there
are many things that have changed for me
in the last 18 months um you know first
and foremost obviously i started
streaming but i think with the lockdown
everything kind of
sort of escalator became much bigger
online and mainly there were many people
stuck at home and they were trying to
follow chess or whatever their interests
were fortunately for me there were still
many online events that i could play and
keep myself busy
to train and prepare for those so i
would say that it didn't really change
my lifestyle too much to be honest it
was not easy for me last one year i had
some health problems also and for this
reason
doctors say you know sports no
no activity i mean i just
played just well i made an entire uh
opening repertoire uncheckable which
took a lot of work i just like published
a full-on opening repertoire based on
playing g4 for white and playing the
classical sicilian the semi slot for
black so that took a lot of work i've
always been very serious about dieting
and physical fitness but it's hard to
maintain the same level when you're
traveling like crazy you're constantly
getting on planes and jet lag so i
really doubled down on that and got back
into the same kind of physical shape
that i was when i was like 20. i might
have picked up some weight you know
i was pretty much staying at home and i
had a very nice time with my wife and
i was it was really i mean for me it
sounds pretty sad but for me was one of
the best periods because you know i had
no
like you know this regular stress that
comes with playing professional chess i
was just at home enjoying a
merry life and generally things that i
usually enjoy just i had much more time
for them
except at some point i was really bored
in the winter and i
tried to learn the rubik's cube
i learned that and now i'm pretty sure
i've forgotten it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we are halfway through the
day here at the st louis rapid and blitz
but it's become the hikaru nakamura show
let's take a look at those standings a
commanding lead 15 points for hikaru a
two and a half point lead over richard
rapport faber carolina fading away a
terrible result here in the blitz one
point out of four also richard rapport
kind of fading one and a half out of
four so his nearest competitors are
fading and hikaru is bringing it home
three out of four absolutely like what
we am saying looked three and a half out
of four but unfortunately he didn't have
a good rapid portion guys let's take a
look at these bearings it is right there
hikaru versus wesley so for sure our
marquee match up wesley so dominant this
year but hasn't been able to show that
form in this tournament grand chester
players shaq mamidarov who's really been
fading oh my goodness versus fabi uh
those players
everybody needs a win now suddenly
between those two absolutely and we have
an action
high we're starting with e4
and they're just adjusting their quizzes
a little exactly will we see a berlin i
think that's exactly where we're going
bishop b5 played knight
no draw i was about to say i want to go
into the ending can we go into the end
game d4 being played knight d6
no
we're going to go
to the well the most drawn
repetition in chess currently by the way
i i have the impression that wesley
as the one who has seen this position
most often
as a cartridge
icarly just said look i'm going to
secure first place i feel like counting
how many times no he's looking at the
monitor to make sure that queen d4 he
could claim a draw but okay all right
and that's it all right enough of this
let's go to what is our backup
good question fabiano caruana's game
let's take a look at that one against
shakuyama medyarov
all right let me bring that up on my
screen
and what do we have here yasser looks
like a
ghosting from this angle
sorry i was just looking at the jeffree
zhang game but uh yes we have a ragosan
between chakra yarmadiarov and fabiano
caruana
this is with the early bishop takes f6
two very early bishop takes f6 queen a4
check being played forcing the knight to
c6 a very strategical battle
there but fabiano he needs points he
doesn't need draws he needs full points
as does shaq now
when you're in really really really bad
form as shaq is i
for myself one of the things i've tried
to do is play a simple clean game and i
think from a strategic point of view for
shaq he's made the right decision he's
going to try to bore his opponent to
death essentially is what he wants
because my gosh it seems to me like
every type of position shaq is just
simply misfiring whether it's tactical
or whether it's strategical or
positional there's finding the blunders
when we talk about form in chess
sometimes we're talking about how do you
play in general it's not that one or two
things are going wrong it's that things
don't click you just can't find plans
you can't find tactics and i agree with
you yasser
he just hasn't been here no no and
something has definitely gone wrong
queen b3 is an invitation for repetition
i think that if you play knight a5 we
will see queen a4 and the knight would
retreat
uh sorry let me just put that on the
board so knight
knight a
a5 hitting the queen but also
attempting to go to knight c4 so that
was what i was meaning about uh this
kind of a repetition um and again as we
started our
uh when we returned from great we were
saying these two players need to win
they need to win this is not my med it's
a gct right the grand chess tour demands
that he get some points and you see
knight a5 none of this draw business no
it's backwards
bobby says well i'm black knight c6 are
you sure you still can repeat if you go
queen b3 right uh but i think i think
shaq's gonna play for a win and he goes
a3
not interested in a draw at all okay
bishop to e6 and bishop to d6 and knight
e7 and let's see who
stands better and why i think black is
fine he does have that pair of bishops
right but strategically in certain
situations this knight on c6 is very
awkwardly placed you want to have it
basically anywhere else because the pawn
on c7 wants to come to c6 solidify the
pawn on d5 it also gets rid of the
problems that you have on the c file the
rook on c1 x-raying this pawn on c7 and
a surprising move really
uh i don't think that that was on my
list of the five most
candidate moves
rook b8 and by the way played quickly as
if yes in these positions you play rook
b8
well right that's why he's 2800 what
rook b8 i'm i
was expecting bishop e6 and bishop d6
bishop d6 and now we're ready to finally
move our knight as has happened knight
c5 knight e7 on the board b4 played
quickly you can see white's expansion on
the queen side and both moves both sides
moves make a lot of sense i'm just not
really sure what my rook's doing on v8
yeah exactly the rook on a8 might
actually support the opportunity of
playing b7
b6 but rook on a8 it's a head scratcher
i have to tell you that uh knight f5
yeah knight five knight into play that
makes a lot of sense i've seen levon
auronia try to play g5 in this position
and g5 played
as i said it yeah
has excelled in this kind of positions
playing this kind of g5 stuff right
starts to get dangerous for both sides
the knight coming to g6 and expanding on
the king side but so often i've seen
black over push ons on the king side and
get hit by an f3 brake absolutely uh the
g5 is definitely double edged but it's
the type of game
that both players need to play and after
g5 knight
d2
again not the first move that jumps to
my mind
g4
trying to trade the bishop on c8 it's
not the most active bishop but it does
defend your entire queen side right the
seven pawn the a6 pawn they're all being
defended by this pawn on this bishop
sorry this bishop on c8 and king g7
played and very quick moves here king g7
h3 rook h8 hinting at h5 coming as a
sacrifice i could take on h5 if i played
it immediately
wow
rook h
hate i mean the mystery
rook moves i was about to say something
about that d5 pawn not being protected i
kind of would have
preferred to see c7 c6 being played but
okay
uh rook h8 queen f3
that makes a great deal of sense if you
ask me and quickly c6 defending that
hanging pawn on d5 the reinforcement of
the knight two to b3 now we always have
to be careful that e3 e4 doesn't come
with some you know
tempo wrecking force right uh at the
moment knight takes d4 is a sufficient
answer but that is lurking uh do i have
to play a move like
knight
knight b3 played already knight d2 to b3
yes knight to the b3 played already
queen g thanks i can imagine quite happy
e3 e4 now starts to
really um concern me as
black
i don't want to
have all my pieces you know tactically
hit bang bang bang bang bang that's why
i like the move queen g6 it moves out of
that position on the 94 he's actually
played bishop c7 also getting out of the
way and that caveman style chess of
queen d6 running checkmate on h2 also
unpinning your knight right that's very
that's very nice and e3 e4
okay it doesn't win material but it was
what shaq wants again with this bishop
on c7
that move well
i would have preferred your queen g6
frankly because now if you take on e4
which has happened knight takes e4
you've got to be pay attention to
another life another hit and i'm not
sure what he's going to do about it
let's see queen g6 on the board you
could play d5 i guess h5 bishop takes f5
and we get something sort of
that is because
i do have this queen c3 check ideas they
seem super annoying
yeah i start to get worried when i see
checks like that coming
so we're expecting the e5 d5 we think
that there's only one really good answer
to that move which is c5 i don't think
it's a good answer because if you take
on f5 here bishop takes f5 bishop takes
f5
do you like queen c3 right away or
knight g3
knight g3
is it tempo they're both juicy yeah
very juicy but the idea of queen c3
check you can keep that in the bands for
just a moment and we are going down this
line yas are already being played queen
c3 f6 bishop takes f5 i expect bishop
takes f5 back and d6 on the board this
is mamadiro's idea you do have the pair
of bishops but guess what i have a ton
of threats that king on g7 and you know
what black's rooks could not be worse
position i know h8 and b8 uh i don't
whoa he took on e4 that pawn keeps
trundling up the board but
that's as far as you get i don't i don't
like this pca knight coming to c5
maybe maybe with the one with or without
rookie one
knight c5 immediately makes a lot of
sense bishop blows it on d5 trying to
control the knight because 96 check was
the big threat you can't take on
on the 81 queen f7 and mama the house
playing quickly putting that pressure on
fabio coroner on the board and on the
clock 47 seconds for the american while
the azeri player has
well over two minutes
let me just refresh my board apologies
for that but i have to get
f4
35 left for him be very very careful
there's a queen g3 sighting
hitting the rook on c7 as well as the
pawn on g4 and that queen coming or
maybe rook f4 as well um i don't like
what's happening to fabby's position
rook f4 and rook takes g4 is scaring the
bejesus out of me at the moment right i
know i'm very scared on the other hand
he has this idea of queen h5 himself
queen h5 queen h1 i mean these are not
joke threats
okay so rook f4 okay maybe i got queen
h5 yeah queen h5 trying to force you to
trade queens he's not played rook f4 he
played rook fe1
puzzling but he's trying to deflect this
rook from the defensive duties
okay he could have also well
hard to guess these moves queen takes
you for grabbing upon with check that
one i definitely understand
um i don't like black's position i know
but i'm wondering knight e6 check bishop
e6 i don't see a knockout blow though no
i don't see it either i do feel that
black's king is more vulnerable but it's
going to take some precise move queen h4
getting on the dark squares robbie needs
to play
rookie one you hack the rooks off the 14
seconds for him
you got to take those rooks off the
board you don't want to see queen h8
check
landing on your doorstep moves faster
moves faster bobby down to 10 seconds on
the clock knight e6 96 i think i move
out of the way
knight d7 and shaq oh
oh my goodness but is it enough is it
enough to win no g4 g4
bishop f3 picks up the pawn suddenly
this pawn is very weak so but can i go
king f2 to e3
make a b line no he's gonna
he's gonna what yeah yeah king three f4
why why not why didn't he play king e5
well why did he allow this why did he
allow king f4 knight h5 check that is a
great question why wouldn't you play key
dude
oh another disaster for fabiana caruana
one out of five losing to shakuyama
madhyava let's switch as we still have
the game of jeffrey shong versus sam
shanklin two talented young players here
from america let's take a look very
quickly at the 2d board so we can kind
of understand what's going on in the
entire world it looks like white watch
out for knight f4 check but it no draw
well we don't know what it is
jeffrey's shot here upper pawn beautiful
night on c6 not that beautiful doesn't
do that much but upon support upon his
pawn
okay but has he allowed
and the players are playing fast and
furious as they
they have seconds left
and
what
[Music]
tricky nights against sam shanklin
blundering on the last second against
jeffrey sean he did it yesterday e7
check cost him a whole rook cost him a
whole rook we can put that on the
analysis board real quick
oh we have that
on yasser's board yes indeed here's the
situation
you do not do this
do not do this
rook takes d5 knight e7 check hits the
king as well as the black rook there
goes a rook there goes sam shanklin oh
that was a painful loss for
how
we have it in slow motion let's check it
out the moment that he takes on tv he
still has seven seconds yeah he plays
rooks rooks
that's a very understandable move right
you and king james jeffrey was
hesitating king e3 and now knight c won
it's a rook i really like knight c when
i think knight e5 makes a lot more sense
right and then after the rook
no he didn't even hesitate he was like
rook takes the fight give me the pawn
and jeffy said give me your rook
oh no
sam sam just blundering a full rook
incredible well
this is where you have some incredibly
gifted tacticians like and they just see
those things in an instant this is an
indication to me that you know
tactically speaking
sam is doing other things he's he's
studying openings he's studying strategy
he's preparing you know different things
tactics aren't like
they're not his father yeah it's not
lightning on the fingertips maurice
uh sum up this round for us please what
happened somehow it was so much fun
listening to you guys as you were
just calling exciting game after
exciting game
one game i would like to focus on is a
game that
showed peter svidler eight-time russian
champ how to get it done he was playing
against richard rapworth and if hikaru
needed any help at all his good buddy
peter just gave it to him look at this
position white is
got white has got nothing for the
opening this is right zilch now it's
time to save himself just pay attention
to this white queen for a moment you're
going to see what happened knight c3
rook d8 queen c2 queen getting chase
rook 81 knight to d4 hitting the queen
again and he decided to play this cutesy
move bishop to e3 only to see queen
before come at him hey what you going to
do with your queen queen to b1 hey what
are you going to do with your queen
queen a-1
he didn't want to go queen c-y on the
queen c3 i mean but still a queen on a1
how did the queen and rook switch
positions you know illegal castle
situations queen to c4
now king h1 bishop to b4 and i said in
this position with your queen in the
corner and you having problems to solve
what is the last thing you'd suspect you
do
unfortunately he remembered yasser
sierwan says grab take upon please
what
oh
you can't do that do stuff like that
well okay bishop takes c3 will take a
pawn back and now there's some little
matuski threats coming this knight is
guarding this square there could be a
mate but check out this line rook takes
rook takes and rook to d1 and at first
you think wait isn't this just mate
until you see f3
and there's a back rank problem you
can't win
any material so a nice little bit of
trickery on his part right here now rook
b8 was really strong in this position it
would be hard to see what you do now
with the attack coming at you you'd have
to drop your bishop back and allow this
position yet again it's just
overwhelming instead he played rook to
d3 and it really didn't matter this was
strong as well he played the same idea
and now the move queen to b1 and here
just winning is give me this
and give me a rook
right like just hand it over right
didn't happen
it didn't happen instead he took on d1
right away and played 8-6 missing a
clean win
off a rook
f3 good for black that he still has a
dominant position give me this pawn a3
give me this pawn because now if you
take
chick hello and gift me that one up
material with an easy win bishop f3 king
g1 trade that off and then after king
takes the game ended here i'm not sure
if he resigned or queen defense or a
champion
like that nevertheless that was after
all the that kind of drama in that game
richard slipping as what bobby slipping
richard slipping
right take a look at those daddy
15 and a half or three point lead over
rich rapport fabera cabrana is now
caught by wesley so 12 points for each
petersburg in 11 and a half i have to
tip my hat to liam oh yeah four and a
half out of five give that man a gold
star amazing i mean at the at this point
it might be
the car and liam's show is uh what we're
talking i mean we kind of discussed it
on the break but we're gonna have to do
some research what was the biggest gap
between first and second in a rapid and
blitz from the grand chess store i think
it was a magnus carlsen
victory in leuven but we're going to
have to check that one okay and
let's take a look of
nakamura's hesitation
at the end of this i think
he was going to uh
claim a draw
and he looked up to see that it was a
three-time repetition and then he said
well why not just play four or five
time repetition this is where he looked
up and he said
have i have i done it
are we there can i should i claim and
draw what's going on
well never mind let me go on i'll play a
few more moves and now it's good enough
and what happened to dominguez do we
have any actual footage of that because
the last position
i wouldn't resign
necessarily was it a clock issue i guess
it was a clock issue because if we go to
that final position yes his position is
quite i would say miserable
where am i going up or down so it was it
was three pawns for the piece
and it must have been a glock issue
because there's no reason for you to
play queen f7 and stop here you're
you're not
nobody resigns this position so it must
have been a clock issue this was a
remarkable game by the way the tension
in this game there was a moment or
several moments when a knight on d4 was
hanging if i can find it um
here we go bishop bishop a3 and right
here rook ad1 the knight on d4 is not
hanging because of the pin b6 c4 the
knight is not hanging and it's just like
we're waiting waiting waiting and then
the moment he backed up then the other
knights started dancing and it got wild
in this position f5 this could have been
one of those games that we would have
really taken a long look at
eventually he sacrificed a piece for
material and ended up
what must have been a clock situation i
can let me just check his time when we
got here it should tell me he was down
to 13 seconds excuse me here and yeah he
must have lost on time let's see we
think we have it on replay i think we
actually have the footage
uh this is very easily very this is way
too early we're talking
talking about the very end of this game
and somehow
lanier i mean he started off wonderfully
on day one
like a stone since wow like just a
straight stone yelling actually died
nine and a half points each i feel like
that game of peter svidler by the way
very human game you know these cycles uh
peter's playing really really well up
until the point that he misses the win
at the rook which would have just been
cementing the game but then he writes
the ship by doing something uh and well
that's
that's peter's been doing well peter's
having a good blitz tournament from the
veteran but but he did lose twice right
he did those to
shaq i believe and to le quan
i want to say on rounds three and four
so he is i think it's fifty percent i
think he's at fifty i mean yeah
good enough in this field fifty percent
i think a lot of people are thrilled to
have them well i just want to boldly
point out the obvious peter was invited
to be come here as a commentator and at
the last moment said oh we want to feed
you to the lions and peter says oh i'm
game
that's impressive
[Laughter]
not many uh commentators uh
guys uh you know would you like to go
into this field not me not so easy and
we're being told we're gonna review our
predictions as maurice is starting to
dance already he's got a lot of shaky
shaky going on
my guy you know he might not be fighting
for first but he's climbing up he's
doing well standings yeah i picked the
dr jekyll of mr hyde player with shaq
and the wrong
doctor showed up yeah good boy and of
course var pic jeffrey it was a creative
uh
i mean he's had his moments but not
consistent enough no it's been jeffrey
he's had his chances i think the biggest
one that he let go for sure his win
against hikaru nakamura
letting that win slip into a draw was a
big mistake yeah as it goes and we do
have the end of the dominguez game let's
see exactly what transpired between uh
the two saint louis and now again
we're back early this is not this is
early i was about to say that lanier was
a former world chess champion uh he
keeps psyching us let's thank you yeah
he's taking us out i mean
tom loves playing with us he just enjoys
saying hey guys i've got a cookie for
you look over here look over here
we got he's got the beginning we're
pretty sure he's lost
oh excuse me i'm pretty sure he lost on
time that game no way yeah yeah but the
question is did he let the seconds to
take down in the way that peter svidler
has or did he just he was down to two
seconds for a while before coming and he
was playing incrementally he was playing
for some time okay and speaking of peter
zwiddler he is having a decent
tournament 50 now he's get he gets white
against icaru
could be the game that we were going to
look forward to as we take a look at our
pairings for this
round six alejandro bobby and shanklin
neither of them performing today
bobby needs to win this one if he wants
to have any chances he's still not out
of the club of contention
very important game there securing his
position yeah petersbuilder as we
mentioned against hikaru nakamura lanier
dominguez against report another player
that hasn't found his sport but rapport
and not impressing today either no and
liam saying hey guys while you're doing
nothing i'm gonna zip up the cross table
i started last today deadline i might
finish
in the middle of the field by the time
uh day four is over remember the ferruga
surge in a recent grand chess tour event
where he does not score a single win in
the rapid portion was dead last
let's play blitz let's play blitz and he
had a monster performance didn't quite
challenge the top spots but he finished
i think top three at the end not bad not
bad at all and
wait how far is he away from the second
place yeah
ten and a half two points
that's nothing
it's not it's not a lot second yeah yeah
it's a very bunched up group
the difference between hikaru and second
place okay is the same difference
as rapport to last
wow i mean literally if three points
three points continues this run yeah
that's quite a run that's that's right
i mean he might end up in
can he end up in clear second
after the tournament's over the answer
is yes yes if he takes up this form the
answer is
keep giving this man blitz stacy
who wants more blitz please
and more blitz we will have for you
and we're being told the third time is
the charm nobody believes tom nobody but
believe that through the magic of
television he's got four seconds left
all right and he's got to make a move
that comes quickly that was quick
rook takes king takes that's got to come
fast king takes okay no problem oh yeah
and now he's got three seconds
now you just
he completely lost track of the that was
a peter fiddler i mean that was five
seconds six months because he started
with six seconds on the clock that's no
way that
is crazy
he's just like he
he blacked out
totally
blacked out forgot about the clock
completely what the heck is going on
don't they understand the clock and
blitz it's a crucial part of the
equipment that we're playing with here
folks you cannot lose track this is a
former world blitz champion yeah wow wow
no way yeah he won and he won the world
blessed championship on the three plus
two control so he's used to the two
second increment absolutely what are you
talking about this is five plus he's
used to getting down to three minutes
when he has when he starts the game
that's right
right any time control he wants to get
down because he's so quick right but
right now his speed is not there the
touch completely eluded him
for this tournament like it's just it's
been terrible on the other hand he's
only three points away from second place
so hikaru up there
from the clouds looking at all the other
players how are you guys doing yeah i am
running away with this tournament man
hikaru is impressive no question about
it and the fact that he
he he did so extraordinarily well in the
rapids i mean we didn't think he was
going to do that well in the rapid he's
clear first and he's just doing great i
mean he's chew chewing along the tray
the hikaru train seems unstoppable at
this point he's in good form
everything's going great he was one
point ahead coming into coming into two
days that's right so he's extended his
lead by two full points right with only
half with only five rounds past right
that's that's not uh yeah that's amazing
it's really bad you know i uh again true
confessions in my case i thought coming
into this event that hikaru might be
rusty because he hadn't played an actual
over-the-board tournament moving
physical pieces in almost two years he's
been in doing it all on remote boy was i
wrong oh i was on the same boat yasser i
thought experience over the board
sometimes it's just absolutely crucial
certainly you're going to have hikaru
being a strong performer in this
tournament but i wasn't thinking he's
just going to run away with it we know
he's a rapid and blitz specialist but
it's been a while since he played and he
comes here and says you guys don't know
what you're talking about
maurice is fooling us as well
that is not just vicara
thank you very much
no i knew that guy
eight hours he used to play eight ten
hours of blitz as a kid every day that's
what he did yeah and his bullet skills
are impo
i mean the guy the guy is incredible i
figured he wouldn't do great at rapid i
admit i wasn't sure what he was going to
do at rapid that's right i just wasn't
sure what he's going to do at rapid but
i didn't think the field was going to
separate themselves from him enough for
them to be able to withstand the tsunami
of his skills in blitz that was the
problem what kind of lead could you put
up
separate yourself from this man who's
the best blitz player on the planet with
no magnus carlsen here to try to pull
him back and he's just showing hey i
could have been down two and i'd be up
now
and here he is hikaru nakamura residing
in los angeles california 33 years of
age we got to fix that it has actually a
five-time right champion that is
for sure and he's had a great tremendous
amount of success in the grand chess
tour
even taking uh
the tour itself in 2018
absolutely and by the way they are off
as we say they are off and it's another
italian i know yasser this is your
favorite opening
again my my mind has turned to mush
where the uh italian is concerned a lot
of the games seem to have all merged
together and the
plans are so elusive for me a little
nuance here in some positions you play
a4 in some positions you play bishop a7
or bishop b6 some positions as black you
go a6 a5 and sometimes that's white you
don't develop you go a4 a5 trying to
never know about that
i never knew about that
many different ways to play the italian
nowadays and look at peter peter he's
just played bishop c1 to e3 saying okay
bishop takes e3 f takes e3 i have double
d pawns but those doubled pawns cover
lots of squares now having said that
bishop e3 fe3 bishop e6 sure looks like
equality to me
i always felt it a little bit unpleasant
to allow the pawn all the way to a5 and
then exchange the bishops
but why
because why white does have the plan of
expanding on the queen side whereas i
thought that black's plans were softened
because of the existence of the pawn on
e3 and maybe that's the reason that
hikaru actually doesn't take on e3 he
plays the move h6 and peter says you
don't want to take my bishop i'm going
to leave it there yeah well again
i just think that the knight on c6 gets
misplaced in these kinds of structures i
i do like bishop e3 fe3 knight e7
paret the knight to the g6 square
so that you can play
for a kingside
uh well i'm not going to say attack but
just reposition this knight
knight
goes to e7 knight goes to g6 and i've
always felt like every top player has
their own style of italian yeah yeah i
think magnus is 97 knight g6 doesn't
matter what position and icaru is the
opposite he's rookie 8 no matter what
position rookie is the plan that he goes
for
and he's done it the rook on a7 makes a
bad impression so uh dropping it back
as soon as possible
seems like the way to go we do not have
that we did see bishop e6 instead yeah
and this takes in d4 kind of positions
where i felt black's a bit uncomfortable
simply because white has the space
advantage on the queen side on the
center and you still have to take that
one extra rook move right okay it has to
come at some point right and now we do
see c4 b4 c4 before
yeah you've got the no question about it
you've got the queen side expansion and
it's going
this move okay because i thought you
might start i thought peter was going to
start with b4 here i do have c5
c5 might slow you down
i think i'll go b4
whoa yeah i don't think i'm going to
slow down at all
i know my i got i get the c5 square for
a knight so
c5 well let me just put this on the
board i'm thinking that hikaru should
play c5 you suggested c5 before takes
queen b3 i must assume everybody has the
same idea uh the same kind of follow-up
knight d7 queen takes c5
queen takes b4 knight c5 that's only one
piece i agree
knight t3 however
yeah i like i like i like white right
there's the problem with the ropes g7
knight coming to b3 to exchange the one
night that can get to c5 right you start
with rookie three and just as you were
saying you put your knight on b3 you get
rid of this one there we go i was c5 on
the board he did play the move uh now
yeah he played knight d7 first so b4
knight c5 we got a very similar
structure to what we were talking about
all differences here because hikaru does
have the move b7 b6 just being just
trying to slow white's
nice queen side attack e6 knight takes
c5 giving up the b file i'm not very
happy about that do i give up the beef i
thought i would be able to compete for
the b file if i give up the b value
right he did play nice seven you didn't
like that idea right okay he still got
b6 on tap
right now
[Music]
oh excuse me let me do that okay and i
still think you put the queen on before
you hint that a threat on c5 will be
playable at some point is he thinking
about c5 immediately actually
and now i can't find the darn game
is he threatening c5 here remember that
yes these are the types of things you
worry about the knight on e7 looks bad
you take with the pawn you have queen c3
double attacking but it's not so clear
just yet right a lot to be worked out
rook ec one played certainly you can see
the plan for white c5 break comes in
this is a strategical disaster for black
so he needs to keep this pawn in check
on c4 right and not be allowed to freely
go to c5 now this is why i was trying
earlier
at least to get in the move
e
7 b6 to take some of the sting out of
the move c4 c5 now queen b3 queen b4
pardon me can be met by queen c7 keeping
everything under guard i imagine that
we're going to start seeing a
remaneuvering of this knight yes 91 93
it's all about the square
and
c4 c5 if white can
engineer that freeing break
peter will be strategically winning it's
not a question of who's bet
winning right it's that important equal
amount of time for both players just
under three minutes for both peter doing
a good job of keeping up his time i can
imagine that peter's looking at 9193
right away as well as queen b4 i think i
would have put it instantly
uh east blade played something else we
said before queen c7 and
here we're waiting one
i think we're be one perhaps a small
nuance to prevent knight c5 okay
makes sense i mean again black is
thinking
how do i get this knight on e7 this
knight on e7 rook on e8 needs to play i
think it's time to play f5 yeah but f5
gives up the eyes i know i know but as
bobby fischer famously said
to get squares you got to give them
and sometimes you just got to give um
give yourself some counter play and are
you right
i'm not saying i'm happy but i'm saying
i got to do something right he did play
knight g6
no he no
oh sorry knight g6 on the board it's
hard to tell quick g3 you know
i don't think you ever allowed this
knight to well though i guess knight f4
yeah g3 played immediately you don't
allow this night no no reason to
and this knight
probably needs to find better pasture
than g6 knight f8 knight h7 knight f6
but i'm saying i don't like to leave the
knight on g6
he goes back to e7 he says i just
yeah he provoked g3 maybe so that f5
comes with a little bit more poison now
that f3 is undefended and queen d2 very
quickly played by peter
okay peter's saying you've got one
idea f5 to break and i'm going to make
this move practically queen d2 not
forcing matters but saying i'm going to
bring my queen back to the only place
you can break again uh one of those
difficult uh
things you've gone queen d2 to b4 this
recognition that maybe your queen is in
the way
and
where you have the first result of the
round shakira mahmoud and like
have split that point f5 already on the
board here by hikaru takes on a five
knight takes a five of course
ricardo is breathing a little bit more
in activity yeah i wasn't wondering
about the move queen d2 because in fact
the queen is not good on d2 maybe queen
before the e1 yeah with the idea that
you could go to queen e4 would have been
more accurate i still like white's
position don't get me wrong icaru is not
out of the woods yet
but uh he's improved oh first for sure
queen a c2
but now
e4
i'm going to go knight to d4 and then to
east
six but you're not getting
five right right right i feel like this
is becoming double edged yeah it's a
three result game after this game e4
and remember a5 is also hanging a knight
d2 played quickly instead taking
advantage of the fact that e3 can always
be met with queen takes f5 i don't have
to destroy my structure rook e1 and now
the c4 is hanging d5 is also hanging by
the way knight takes d5 as a possibility
yeah so something like rookie 5 94
knight d5
is one line of play
now unfortunately the desert desirable
e3 is met by queen takes f5 and in this
case
capturing on d2
does nothing the the pawn is quickly
corralled after knight on b3 takes c2 so
the move e3
uh
fails tactically rookie five and knight
d5
any other queen e7
ikaro finally under
we're going straight into the queen f5
pawn takes knight takes everything all
right five on hanging
a5 perhaps ah if i was hanging at the
end although that's a strange trade
five right no you don't want to give up
that e4 pawn for the eight and isn't
rook takes b7 so i can go rook takes e8
rook takes e8 rook b7 queen d2 queen g6
no because that queen you want check
king ji to queen e4 would trace the
queens at least but i like this move
knight e ford
i ever did anybody ever call you a party
pooper
minute
[Music]
this is where hikaru
separates himself from he really really
does he's extraordinary
when both sides are
are really really low on the clock
somehow he has this
extraordinary ability to
change the position there's a g7
defending the seventh rank and i don't
like for peter that he allowed this
queen takes d6 rook f7
is the issue and peter's saying
and look at this
once again hikaru landing on his feet
he has the active rooks he has the
active queen
i like what he's done
uh
what hikaru has done pardon me and king
h8 and a pawn
queen e7 picking up that b7 pawn unless
you play rugby but really don't think no
i wanted to play
king g8 we might see d7 we might see a
repetition here
okay because
he's good
no he won't well why not he has to go
this way he has to go back right
and yeah there's the draw between
petersville and hikarnaka let's jump
straight into the wesley soul game
against jeffrey shong that is going to
be quite important what's going on oh i
see a bishop on b4 i see it over
just over bishop before check and bishop
takes d7 bishop takes d7 queen takes me
to his checkmate
but rook do you want that skewer yeah
well what's going on bishop takes b2
king b king b1 forced box as we say
queen e4 check you don't have time to
take on b5 because i assume you got
mated
but we do have bishop to d3 seven
seconds left
he must move is it a
wesley letting his time go down
but no this is uh too many pieces right
king d3 end of the checks a4 a4 no
that's it that's going to be resigns
whoa an important win there for wesley
saw as fabiano caruana has
uh way we still have
what about richard and
richard currently in second place
against lanier dominguez take a look at
the position nine seconds for linear
try to bring that up onto two you got it
there we go i got it uh a complicated it
looks like why
choice for choice that rook on asics is
definitely leveraged in the position it
reminds me of the game the linear beat
against uh jeffrey schong in the first
day
with that structure how to pass a pawn
yes
yes exactly
lanier feeling it right now he's got the
advantage no question about it
but he has
so badly mangled his time
uh management in the in this event
no exception here five seconds for
linear dominguez richard was still 17
seconds knight g4
get that knight on f2 into play he
didn't play it he played rook
a
rook a8 there f6 finally defending this
pawn on e5 i was wondering why it was ha
hanging for so long favia i'm getting
confirmation did win that game i'm sure
maurice would give us much she needed
much respect for fabi because he has
just been flip-flopping oh yeah more
flopping than flipping by the way but
the space the pace that richard plays is
so beautiful impressive doesn't give any
any chance
yeah to accumulate any time so we have
been seeing a repetition the rook has
been going back and forth between a8 a3
and a5
and
uh i wouldn't be surprised no richard is
saying
hey i want to win look i've seen how you
have
gifted
so many points away and i i'm on time
why this knight coming to e6 it's knight
coming to d4 unfortunately this bishop
on b8 is pretty terrible yeah even on
even if you were given a number of moves
to move your bishop around
not easy
oh
richard smelly blood here before
that that's
oh
but look lanier is playing
finally
just blundering no it's just blundering
he's got a structure he'd be bored he's
off material
i missed who was on move sorry about
that yeah knight e6 i know this is just
two pawns right it's just two pawns it's
just
like we are just not able to find his
form with a sweet king by the way for
black no counter play there now it's
three connected passers
right no that's that's with d3 uh c5 c5
rolling baby and that bishop by the way
on b8 that was doing that
you fight with trickery yeah there was
some trickery there but that d3 move
shuts down the diagonal well he has one
i don't think it's as powerful as three
no
and three connected passes and he's
they're just blitzing now because the
time situation is so bad
that lanier is just hoping but this pawn
is flying and you have no no counter
play against all these pawns one second
he was down two and here they come again
two seconds one second he's taken upon
and a
rook dropped he's hoping for what
nothing nothing
and it's over lanier dominguez loses
that game richard reported
his second place by the way that was a
kind of a game that hikaru on black you
can see hikaru pushing his luck from
that position right right but when his
opponent is especially short on time he
does that but richard looking fantastic
very impressive there in this game but
maurice you have to take us through
another important game duel between
former u.s champions fabiano carrana and
sam shanklin big one for the standings
fave needed a winner he got it
uh he was
handed it over okay
check it out big time gift
sam played marvelously to get this
position
no problems for black you got one square
congratulations i got the lines knights
coming in
everything black could hope for no
attack over here to worry about things
are good things get better bishop g2 h6
let's slow you down and now
bishop f1 all right i'll back up what
you got knight d5 bishop to g5 move your
queen
rook to c5 all good you got a paper
tiger on this knight on d5 you're not
doing any damage right now
bishop d3 whoa whoa whoa
hello let's
bing hit you in the head with rook takes
c3 typical exchange sacrifice and here
knight f6 could have played g6 according
to the engine but this is even fine as
well king b2 panic mode queen to b6
bringing the queen closer now rook to e4
please take my rook take take it just
just do something no we don't want your
stinking rook we want this pawn to
everything's collapsing falling apart
now h4 give us that one too what's the
point of that black's got material full
compensation and attack rolling a bad
king
queen f5 hoping against hope now all he
has to do is rook is under attack
give me a pawn just take it just i got
it queen c5 is coming a3 is going to
hang in a second this there's no mates
on the back rank for him to worry about
he can always play g6 if he needs to
this would have been crushing winning
yeah what did he do
he backed away
backed his night out and watch what
happened we just saw the momentum
completely on his side watch this shift
queen d7
the knight's not really attacked but
rook d8 uh
pawn number one
queen c7 move your queen away queen a7
pawn number two
i was winning
i was winning what happened here queen
c7 before nothing on the b line just up
material now with dominant position the
game didn't last much longer queen b7
got down to an ending and uh you can
just imagine uh it it went a while we
won't even bother we'll go to the
terrifying turnaround to the to the
final position here he even got some
stuff on this side but this a-pawn was
too much what a turnaround he just
backed up when he should have finished
him off
gifted bobby that game
rook c3 and queen c5 big big big miss
important win for fabi how does it
affect the standings let's take a look
because it's also a huge win for richard
rapport as hikarna kamura let's say only
drew his game right likely
let's say getting there no not really
two and a half points still between
hikaru nakamura and richard report
fabiano caruana there with 13 points
also wesley so winning his game keeping
that pressure on second place 13 points
for wesley so peters valerie with 12
after that draw shakuyama medyarov also
with 11 and a half with another draw
jeffrey shanghai cornelium with 11 and
sam shanklin and lanier i'm
just not finding their form liam
crawling up the table with five out of
six
yes sam has given up five goose eggs
out of six that is not he said that he
worked on his rapid he's going to be
needing the work on his blitzkills
overnight big he's on top of a loss he's
a number he actually told us himself
right if there is a full day break after
i have a loss then it's very easy for me
to recover and he admitted himself when
he has a loss
a couple losses on the same day he
easily goes on tilt loses many and man
five games losses today that's a lot but
beautiful beautiful play by sam to get
himself into this winning position
but he didn't seal the deal maurice no
he didn't there's something i wanted to
show you guys because it's just so
gorgeous
didn't work out completely didn't finish
the deal although he did win the game in
the end wesley so in this position we've
seen him similar position uh where the
the king was on e8 who did he beat was
it chakriar or who did he beat with the
idea of h4 h5 bishop it was sam sam
that's right so jeffrey decides to play
the same line but plays king f8 instead
of castling into it and look at what
this pawn is hanging right look at what
he does to exploit the move rook b8 this
next move is gorgeous take a look knight
to e2
a deep move saying take my pawn please
rook takes
rook takes
queen takes four all right
i just took your pawn you can't take on
c6 ponte because my queen is guarding
all the way in the back row
e4
d takes e4 f takes e4 now your queen
can't take anything move away because
rook c6 is an ever-present threat bishop
f4 is a threat you move your rook away
b7 is hanging that knight e2 retreat
just sweet in the position and rook v8
played give me that now knight takes
here is where wesley didn't seal the
deal with an amazing move he paused for
a moment instead of playing this move
which looked uh
like the obvious move to play i think he
thought maybe the queen could come back
after a trade the problem is if you do
this and this and try to guard that
night well then sorry uh hello and wake
up
coffee he missed
that point and the game still had some
kind of drama but he ended up winning
because of the force of his position
anyway but i love that night back those
retreating moves and then the hidden
discovery with e4 to bring the bishop
out those are not easy to see
world-class stuff very very nice indeed
thank you for that maurice very nice
wow what a tournament we've had so far
it's been the hikaru show yeah
and
but let's remember you guys can join us
here we have some a merchandise from the
st louis rapid and blitz and check out
this shirt and mask says grand chester
on it this shirt is actually the one
that sam shankland is using yeah
biggest endorsement at the moment i
wouldn't go there with that but i do
love
what's coming up next yeah you can find
this beautiful jackets
i actually love these they're so
comfortable they're so pretty you can
get them at
qboutiquestl.com these are the new
versions of the wrap and blitz jackets
yeah represent the grand chester very
very very nice and what about our next
round what does it look like let's take
a look it is going to be liquin lim
against fabiano corona richard report
against mahmoud yarov nakamura against a
weakened dominguez yeah that's one we
probably need to avert our eyes
yeah that might not be pretty jeffree
strong against peter svidler and sam
shanklin he is playing against wesley so
sam needs to come back into this
tournament well we have to congratulate
uh
nakamura on his exhibition but i want to
congratulate you wesley so you was a
good pick very good pick that's nice
exhibition
the guy's like type of third
he's out of the tour he's not going to
win your congratulations also reigns
what is that hans komak hans kamak he
was the arbiter in the bobby fischer u.s
championship uh there we go this is what
we were talking about
nakamura
by don't worry yasser there will always
be another tournament exactly
uh we uh hans kamak was the arbiter in
the event that uh bobby fischer went
with a perfect score so at the closing
ceremony the arbiter walked up to larry
evans and said congratulations on your
tournament victory he was second was
larry evans and he turned to bobby and
said congratulations on your exhibition
[Laughter]
what a dominant performance that was
yeah yeah
well take a very very short break guys
don't go anywhere we have round seven
action coming right at the end of this
commercial break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we are about to start round
seven of the st louis rapido blitz blitz
section it's been fast and furious but
take us to our leaderboard oh it's
hikaru nakamura a huge score of 16
points maintaining that two and a half
point advantage over richard report and
remember it's fabiano carona and wesley
so both on 13 points but wesley's
surging fabiano fading as you can see
with that four out of four points for
wesley in the blitz score it's fabies
too and he's
by the way he just got a victory so he
was actually one out of five so that was
not good much needed one on round seven
we're gonna take a look at a lot of
interesting chess but i think we're
actually gonna focus on the best
performer of the day so far in the blitz
la quang liam against fabiano caruana
absolutely we got to give him some love
as he has really performed extremely
well with your rapport
nakamura against dominguez
no i'm saying that looks bad i'm going
to avert my eyes i think that uh the
blitz demon
known as hikaru nakamura takes that one
because liam is just pardon me uh lanier
is just not in the form he needs to be
together
with that spicy big mood
d6 inviting knight c3 and e4 does he
play the perk defense no i think
sometimes he goes bishop f5 in this
exact position no
because he just doesn't play this move
order but okay he's inviting
i do know my boy wants it
it's a kind of a funny position after
knight h4 bishop d7
bishop back to d3 e4 you get a position
after e5 where knight f3 you get the
move bishop d7 for free
funny funny business bishop g5 uh i like
this move and fabio already thinking i
think most of the time you want to go
oh d5 taking advantage of the night
being on c3 we're going to get a very
normal structure at the end of the day
with a very peculiar movie we're gonna
get a very
strange position bishop d3
are you going to trade i don't think so
think you're playing bishop g6 or knight
e4 is that crazy knight e4 might be
crazy bishop g6 yeah a lot more sane i
think
the bishop in a safe square but castle's
95 i do think that
white has got some initiative after this
move knight e5 followed by f4 the knight
on c3
not ideal but
not not terrible
fixing that immediately going e4 with
that break
ambitious but at the same time if i take
one e4 and go bishop e7 exactly
right well i've brought the knight on c3
i'm going to trade on f6 it really
reminds me of a rubenstein french that's
right but i teleported my bishop to g6
nice teleportation
not a bad one at all not bad
nicely done and it is indeed as you said
a rubenstein french with the light
squared bishops coming off the board
that and then i'm just saying he will be
very pleased with the real problems here
for the black side what we've been
talking about is this bishop on c8 that
you would see
in a rubenstein french is actually on
this wonderful diagonal
on g6
not behind the pawn on e6 and we think
that black is equalized rather
comfortably thanks to that nuance yeah
he's going to be preparing the break c5
at some point to give activity to his
knight on d7 i think it's coming up very
very very quickly yeah actually and
bishop takes gsa hd
you know a lot of people like to say
those are double pawns
i like those double pawns normally i'm
not a big fan of the double pawns but in
this particular case as a karo khan
player i've had this structure so often
in my career i've grown comfortable
absolutely the pawn on g6 does a
wonderful job at defending certain
important positions including if i
decide to put the pawn on e6 somewhere
else like on e5 right i don't have to
worry about it
so important c5 was played at a trade
knight takes d4 a little concerned about
this knight on g3
again when the knight on g3
is facing a pawn on g6 and the squares
h5 and f5 are both covered the knight
tends to suffer a7 a6 just stopping any
uh perspectives for the knight of
jumping to b5 and later to d6
again i think black has comfortably
equalized can he get more
i think the way you start is you connect
the rooks with queen c7 you bring a
rooks to the center of the board and you
hope
now your eventual idea of e5 will bear
fruit and as he listens to you queen c7
being played these guys are really good
i have a feeling that i would rather be
black in this position already it it
it's i'm warming up to it a lot right i
mean um
from white's point of view what is white
strong well yes he does have the queen
side majority so let's rock this rock
and roll b4 let's get this baby sharp
because he doesn't do anything get
steamrolled in the center he says let me
get that spatial advantage on the other
side of the board may i mm-hmm push him
baby push him
gotta push him
there you go e4 and c5 on white's agenda
maybe black should take time out to play
the move b7 and that has to stop it
rook c8 coming not only to attack the
pawn on c4 but also to defend the
weakened square on c6 exactly i i
a little bit worried about those kind of
positions right right um
i'm just wondering
i mean sometimes you really want to get
in these moves rook e8 e5 so that you
can play a5 and sometimes that tempo of
bring bringing a rook to c8 or leaving
it on a8 can make all the difference in
the world and hence fabi looking a
little bit deeper in the position that's
a very quick win by young jeffrey
a big miss by peter svidler what
caster's opening disastrous opening i'm
being told by the russian chess player
and jeffrey taking full advantage of it
winning
in whoa almost no time at all peter has
not been giving away the gifts but i
guess
something caught up yeah yeah yeah that
one i meant in the blitz uh but yes i i
like what fabby has done uh he has
played rookie eight he's prepping his
majority remember white's already
playing for b4 c5 you want to play e5
you want to drive this knight away from
the b5 square so you can get in the move
a5 you want to
on a really good day you want to force
white to play the move uh b5 which is a
strategic disaster for white getting up
to c5 square don't go there and you were
mentioning what fischer had said that to
gain a square you have to give up a
square and in this case what the problem
with e5 is you kind of give up the d5
square and you see that knight c2
retreat instead of knight b3 the knight
wants to go to e3 go to that strong
position on d5 exactly but again that
knight on c2 is also
trying to discourage a five and this
bishop don't forget it's lurking
it's eyeballing that pawn on b4 i really
would like to get in the move a6 a5
right here and he's done it
as
including as you said knight e3 uh i
love this type of chess this battle of
ideas right right you got your trumps
the queen side majority i've got my
trumps the center slash kingside
majority
who was going to come ahead exactly
man i cannot play b5 not only because a3
is hanging but it's just such a bad
strategical move i would rather even
play the move c5 but i don't know if i
can make it work c5
takes on c5 b5 is that a positional
sacrifice i could consider
yes because the knight on c4 looks good
from that percent perspective because of
what you just said c5 i'd probably play
a b
in order to open up the a file for my
rook i was worried about c6 there though
not anymore
opening up some files but i don't think
if i was going to be too scared of this
no on the contrary if i'm fabby i'm
planting queen f4 or queen e5 on the
board well i was thinking queen f4 for
the idea of bishop purposes of bishop d6
and e3 you can still do it remember that
after e3 the knight is going to be
hanging to the bishop on d6 good point
yeah you're absolutely on the button
no i'm like oh you're sharp today yeah
sometimes like what's going on
we do have a title today
six i think it's kind of a bailout
option trying to trade off all the pawns
i think bishop takes before is okay but
i don't know if hobby wants to
i know because
you you want to combine e3 bishop takes
b4 and bishop c5 tactics somehow right
uh
b5 queen b5 e3 that might be the
sacrifice that brings you some joy i'm a
little bit worried about b5 d6
yeah i don't really do not want to have
my bishop buried right i want bishop d6
and i want e3 but you can't play both
why not bishop d6
now bishop d6 i was thinking you go
queen e4
queen takes e4
i didn't want that
i didn't want that that's right yeah oh
sorry
queen takes e4 very nice it wouldn't be
more than equality but
i think i'm trying to get more than that
as black here that's what i'm trying for
as well i'm aspiring to something like
bishop takes b4 and rook a1 how do i get
rook a1 and e3 no but fabi's taking a
long think on this how about
rook a1 rook b6 e3
probably thinking a minute i don't know
no way
seconds this is
15 seconds no this is not good time
management yeah even if it comes up with
a good move it doesn't matter right
88 plate that has to be a tricky move
because if you take on b6 i think you do
go e3 i'm not sure no thanks for b6
bishop d6 he says i don't want these
pawns oh because queen takes e4 now
you've defended
that idea so he has e3 on the agenda but
there's this beautiful move knight f1
it's just defending everything i'm maybe
really under estimating the defensive
resources of white in this position
exactly that knight on f1 is doing a
great job at preventing both queen h2
gets by the way let's go bobby playing
for three results
f5 f4 f3 coming that feels a little bit
suicidal but i didn't have a better
suggestion but why suicidal well because
you're expo you're everybody's uh
exposed yeah i understand about rook c6
f4 on the board f3 tummy is not a real
threat
why is it a real thing
queen g5 and queen h5
queen
g5 okay so
let's say i play rookie one defending uh
oh i don't want to
no no no no no no i don't want to leave
oh he's saying five black ones saying do
your worst prove it baby i'm gonna push
it i live in saint louis
show me show me
show me state
i i go f3 i don't understand okay so f3
gf3 queen h5 is what you suggested yeah
maybe f3 you just go queen e3 defend
that way
and after f3 queen e3 you take on g2 oh
that's instant queen g5 what what
that was so easy for white to play
nobody believes you
rook e1 just sidestepping e2 rookie one
you have to watch out a little bit about
e2 and bishop b4 though
seriously i have to watch adam because
rook takes d5 is coming oh i'm sorry
yeah so you cannot play rookie one
rookie one actually loses yeah
actually how do you defend okay
i think somebody believes him yeah
somebody believes him i don't see the
defense knight no e2 must be game over
rookie one bishop b4 that's game over
i'm going to take on d5 gonna take play
rook d1 just take that right
wow
favi doing it rook takes d5 take that
five stop thinking just take the pawn
exactly well
he's maybe thinking about g6 g5 he was
thinking about his g pawn he defied
decided to defend it come on look behind
the pawn let's go
let's go
big game because there's a master class
that sam is putting on wesley so no way
oh g5 let's go
right
and that game i'm being told it's over
wow sam shackling takes down wesley so
huge you shouldn't rook to b2 yeah stop
thinking just trade the rooks win that
pawn
what yeah that's fine you're gonna
afford yes
sorry
what's going on
g5 there's another g pawn g6 g5 g7 is
one of those double functions yeah
the other one i like those double pawns
oh g5 is a great move you'll it really
is and then i guess move the knight
because you lose that immediately
i think it's time to play rookie sex
uh repeat why did you
oh okay
what
why did he play rook b7
uh but it's just easily winning right
uh it is an exchange
i'm not
remembering the camera no this is very
different are you sure
why
well by the way fabi will be one of
those players who would really know
how to technically win this position so
you've got to put your rook on e5 and
your king
crosses to d5 yeah
i mean it's not
immediate win but it's it's a win it's
slow but sure you think yeah by the way
is
94 rook takes e4 yes at some point that
will be winning yes that's the problem
you can't afford a
king and pawn end game yeah you can even
start thinking about it already i was
about to say it sure he sure was
he's keeping the rookie
very boring
kingdom
keeping the rook at a very safe distance
away from the night so you don't fall
victim to any forks this is over yeah
this is over and now it's he doesn't
know what to do
and takes on f3 and king to g3 i think
is the most taken second
this is over
and again keeping that rook away from
nice play
bobby an important win there for the
american
world number two everything's done and
being told richard rapport drew his game
against shakuyama medyarov which i
believe means favi catches richard he's
back in the tie for a second he's black
in the tie for a second wow
okay what an important maurice i i need
to see this game what happened to peter
and for that matter wesley and wesley so
had that matter those seemed like huge
results not just because of
what happened you said a master class in
one peter getting crushed on the opening
sam shanklin
zero half a point out of six so five
losses and then giving a master class
what these guys are good right they are
really good good come on maurice yes
well we had a great fellow
peter's pet opening the grunt fight
he's going to lose in something like
five moves what from this position how's
that possible h4 challenging him e6 and
now h takes g5 and what he should do is
take back on g5 just take it back on g5
he decided he could take on d5 because
after g takes h6
he's tempoing the queen hitting the
queen no hitting the knight
no problem until the move
queen c1 showed up at his doorstep
and now the problem is you can't take
this knight actually it's what he did he
took the knight and instantly queen g5
and he's going to get mated nobody can
guard the mission nobody's going to get
made queen yeah
nobody else can help that was it game
over he walked right into
uh his own funeral
incredible finish for peter uh literally
20 move was 21 moves and he had to
resign so really terrible result for him
there
sam on the other hand what he did to
to uh wesley was incredible
first he started with a better position
uh from here
b3 so this position he said all right
let's go d4 queen g3 bishop d6 bishop to
f4 let's trade off this pair of bishops
and we're going to just talk to your one
weakness right here for a while f3 rook
b8 let's focus on this weakness rook d8
rook ac1 queen a5 rook c2 g6 now i'm
going to jump ahead a couple of moves to
here h4 he got a rook on the seventh
rank
and now wesley has to worry he played
rook c8 he said i'm keeping my rook on
the seventh ring let's start there an h5
stopping any kind of advances and now
the move queen f4
bishop d5 i'm going to avoid some of the
shots he could have played but rook to
d8 here queen e5 slowly but surely a5
noticing the weakness on this a5 pawn
and now queen to e7 and look at this i
have to say this is where sam did slip
one part part for sure
but who can blame him there's a win here
a win
but it's extraordinary bishop takes g6
is winning on the spot because he fights
because of queen takes and rook to c5
you can't move this bishop nor can you
guard it right because of rook to g5
coming and there's no way to physically
take care of business queen e6 is made
by queen g5 check and you drop the
bishop so sam did miss that move in this
moment but it didn't matter because of
the way he handled his business i'm just
going to play one move at a time watch
sam let's trade queens let's do that no
problem let me go for that pawn let me
guard that one and wesley tried his best
to try to hold the position together he
said i'm bringing my king in i'm playing
g4 and it's just straight forward
on his part king e7 let me advance this
one oh and nice pasta that's a pass pawn
brook g8 trying for some tricks
no sorry no tricks for you let's trade
down let me get that one
and
rook b6 king e7 b4
peasy young geezy sam took care of
business and wesley decide to stop here
because there's just two past pawns
no problem for sam
big result for our standings just huge
as
suddenly fabi has re-risen into second
place in a tie with richard on the crypt
he was he was buried yeah he was out in
the [ __ ] that he has risen he has risen
and importantly against lee kuan yew who
has had a magnificent day even with that
loss he's still leading in let's call it
the blitz tournament and hikaru nakamura
two and a half points he only drew
against dominguez
yasser your prediction there didn't i oh
lanier an apology he defended very very
well with the black pieces held the uh
naka express to a draw wesley saw it
there with 13 points peters fiddler
dropping down a bit there with 12 points
allowing jeffrey shang actually to catch
him with 12. shakira madyarov somehow
still still somehow in the middle of the
field and shaq riyar for grand chester
purposes
needs a result in the remaining games
especially tomorrow maybe shaq is on
plus one today
four out of seven yeah that's plus
amazing amazing right i don't understand
it which could he even beat
where we will look at it
would have to win two games and speaking
of a break we're going to take a short
one so we get our batteries recharged
going into the last two rounds of the
day but we're going to leave you with
the caspar of chess.com lesson enjoy and
we'll be right back very nice
[Music]
[Music]
in this episode i want to show you a
study by sarichef composed in 1928
this study presents
an additional twist to the
very famous weighty maneuver
that every
every school boy interested in chess
should know
if we look at the position
white is a bishop down
here
but
he has the option of promoting his pawn
while
black spawn is actually very far away
from promotion
we think at first that it's possible to
simply promote
but it fails to bishop f5 check
p and which is a skewer
and after king c7 you attack the pawn on
b7 but black
takes the queen
and i cannot take back the pawn on b7 i
can take the bishop but obviously it's
upon once towards promotion here
so the obvious move
certainly doesn't work
so now there
are other ways to try and promote the
pawn the obvious one would be to play
king to e6 to prevent bishop f5
but black simply renews the threat
with king e4
and after
c8 queen bishop f5 check still is a win
for black
so now it's time to remember that
we don't need to promote the pawn
to make a draw
what we want is to actually take this
pawn on b7
so
we're running towards b7 with king d6
it doesn't work because now i play
bishop f5 of course to prevent the
promotion and if i go keen c5 i'll
protect the pawn at the same time as
covering ch square
after king b6 i can get my king
and if king a7
b5 now
so i can face king b8 and my pawn is
already running to
promotion
so this doesn't work as well
so
what are the other ways
now we realize already that this pawn
is covering c6
and this is what is enduring
white's king
advancement
so
[Music]
we come to the conclusion that we have
to make this pawn move and the only way
to do that is to play king c8
now the pawn has to move if bishop
before king b8
and c8 queen is too big a threat
so black goes b5
and now this is one of the most pleasing
aspects of chess
and chess studies in general is that the
possibility you have to
switch
back
so it means that i just move my king to
c8 and now i'm bringing it back to d7
what did i gain
for the moment nothing because i still
don't threaten the promotion bishop f5
is still a threat
um so black simply plays b4
again king e6 king e4
is no use because bishop f5 is still
happening
and now is the moment where the waiting
maneuver kicks in
so you go king d6 this time
after bishop f5
when the pawn was on b7 we had to go
through c5 and b6
to get to the pawn but it didn't work
now the pawn is on b4 and it's still far
away from the king which is
very helpful
so the key move is king e5
so it seems like we're going away from
the pawn
but the important thing is we're
attacking the bishop
and by attacking the bishop we win one
essential tempe
where black spawn cannot move black's
bishop has to move
because it is under attack
and after bishop c8
now i can play king g4
and no black skin cannot come back to
protect this pawn
the pawn cannot run after b3 king c3 the
pawn will fall i mean you could add
let's say bishop e6 after which i
promote
bishop takes king takes the pawn and we
can shake ends
and make a draw
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this exciting day of
blitz we have two more rounds for all of
you and we have some great ones let's
take a look first at where we stand
after seven rounds of blitz yasser all
over the place absolutely but liam has
got the five he's he's the one who's
performing the best even though he just
lost
that was a big game as familiar
marijuana catches richard report there
on second place both of them scoring 11
in the rapid and three in the blitz so
far they have 14 points and wesley saw
surging a little bit there four points
striking distance but sam shanklin just
took him down and a master class as
marie showed us absolutely and we are
going to have a great round date
certainly the duel of the americans is
what's going to keep us thrilled karana
versus so wesley needing a win but does
have the black pieces exactly and again
grand chess tour points are so crucial
wesley's thinking gotta stay ahead of
shaq so come on kikaru uh
show your stuff and knock down
a competitor absolutely meanwhile the
near dominus will play and here's
jeffrey shong svidler against shankland
and lek juan gleam the surging like only
a little bit stopped there in the last
round but still he wants to accumulate
points against richard rufford berosian
verusian during the break kind of came
up to me and said you see there was a
reason why i picked jeffrey i mean he's
had some moments oh certainly that's a
little inconsistent with the exhibition
of peter spidler's position queen g5
oh oh dear oh dear and there we go e4 by
fabi wesley barely made it to the round
adjusting his pieces
very unusually wesley has been a little
bit tardy i want to say normally he's
really right on the clock but sometimes
especially in the rapid he was uh
interestingly he's not going for berlin
okay did he want to allow the drawing
repetition and he didn't go
before an open either so
a4
marshall yeah favi is not declined
quickly declined with a4 b4 so we have
an anti-marshal on the board with a5
yes both of these players studying this
position very heavily they were both
gladiators of this opening fabi with
both colors as well as wesley c3 i'm
more familiar with ideas of d3 and
knight d2 and trying to bring a knight
quickly to c4 c3
is the latest and greatest no this is
all well known all the way the st3
bishop c4 nothing new under the sun in
this position
a fascinating position in which the a6
pawn is a weakness for the rest of the
game but it's hard to take even when the
bishop
i was about to say even when the bishop
leaves his defense
it's untouchable bishop takes a6 i'm
assuming rook a8 yeah it always works
bishop b7 rook takes a5 hits that rook
on a1 gotcha makes sense
h3
bishop h
and d3 five very sensible move the
knight is gonna come to d2 maybe all the
way to g3 can black make any really good
use out of this
pin
i mean unless you're playing f5 really
really fast this pin on f3 doesn't feel
like it comes with
uh
too much of a punch yeah i i don't
really know what the bishop is doing
there in this position
i know that it's actually okay to play
like this
but whoa
knight takes a5 yeah we should have seen
that coming right
there
there was this knight on b1
unprotected the rook was overworked
defending the b1
as b1 knight as well as the pawn on a5
and
it's not well after i see that i feel
equality quality is fine yeah black is
up a pawn but that's not going to last
very long it can take a6 either this
move or whenever i feel like it right so
i don't think that's more than equal but
i think black solved these problems no
question about it that
fabi
must not be very pleased by this
this change g
four four what what what fighting
complications do you take on g4 yeah i
think i do and why do you do it in five
seconds because knight takes a g4 hd4
bishop takes g4 i've got two pawns he's
asking for it yeah and the west work on
c1 i could go rook takes c1 bishop takes
f3
wes they didn't even think about it
he didn't believe it they didn't believe
it
sometimes you trust your opponent you
know and in this case on the other hand
this bishop
for a blitz game it gives me it gives me
i feel like i i would have gone for it i
really would have done this yeah it just
had that right feel to it yeah it's hard
to resist this temptation it blitzes
about instinct and in this case wesley
just said i don't have enough i don't
have enough development my queen on d8
the rook on f8 aren't participating in
the attack
but having said that two pawns
it was three years you haven't taken an
asia that's true it was three so by the
way
look at this crafty little move knight
takes g4 queen
luckily for fabi the rook is currently
privileged yes it's not actually a
double attack exactly did you get out of
this knight takes g4 business king
h
one question
f1 i don't know knight h4
maybe knight h
knight takes g4 ah knocking h2 played
very similar idea oh i think you're
actually going to put the king on jake i
don't know i don't know i don't think
i'm going to do that no
um but i think he his idea was he needed
to defend the pawn on h3 because h7 h5
could have been a move
that uh
well
wesley has by the way h5 again h5 you go
to g5 right yes of course
uh the bishop on c i was about to go
knight g4 check
hghg and play bishop takes g5 until i
notice there is a black square bishop on
c1 defending the g5 pawn right
i
don't
think that the wesley is in deep trouble
but somehow i like white's position a
bit more the space advantage the weak
bishop on g6 and i think that's why he
played this move king h8 he didn't find
the concrete plan yeah the bishop on c4
having a better view than the bishop on
g6 i'm still for me the jury's still out
i think a lot will depend upon a
resolution on the king side when i play
a move like h5 g5 knight h7 how do
things um
break out cc6
at a break in the center with the move
d5 rook a7 taking advantage of the
weekend seventh ranked bishop d8 played
instantly as you needed to defend that
and the bishop is going to come out to
b6 by the way if that bishop does come
out to b6
uh easy easily the tables could turn
yeah i think bishop b3 is something
we're going to see in the very near
future unless d5 is an issue
could be
it could be a
double potential
i was about to say
it was funny if the pawn was on e6
bishop a6 would trap the black queen
it's like what
yeah
actually surviving by the minimum right
bishop basically
i know i was like can i hunt down the
queen it doesn't work no it doesn't but
and bishop whoa
six bishop e3 uh i think the the reason
of bishop a6 is that d5 doesn't come
with a tempo
really yeah i think so i mean why else
do you put the bishop on a6 why is the
bishop good on a6 in any event i'm not
really sure i'm not sure either um but
you can d5 bishop c5 yeah okay i will uh
i'll accept that but maybe rookie eight
prepping d5 rookie knight g5 though i
apologize yeah then you get trapped
because of c4 yeah a bingo
no you cannot play that you might i
don't like h6 never mind
i don't like it but it may be necessary
h7h6 i need to
unless i'm willing to play d5 bishops
here whoa
now he's sacrificed oh now he stacks
tonight like what what
well it's wesley so i'm sure he's
calculated something
how
does he
is threatening bishop h5
he's got 92 very quickly and so we we
definitely want to check here the
queen's on the board with queen h4 check
five runs kind of into rook h1
excuse me you're absolutely right rook
h1 is on white's agenda which means
bishop h5 f3 no i'm not it doesn't help
you what's the follow-up here i don't
know
i mean saying it's bad for black bad for
black but you know what it's crazy and
we love it
one yeah
one is huge that's gonna just have six
you gotta go back and then i have a
knight yeah exactly an extra piece i
think you take on f5
what a moment to do it right bizarre
right just exactly that in that turn so
knight e4 queen g6 check knight g3 i
think i go queen h5 and you covered the
g6 square and queen h5 on the board just
so then you don't i understand there
were yeah i and i forgot by the way that
bishop takes d3 the bishop on a6 is
defending and you are asking what is
that bishop doing it has a huge
performance
uh very important part knight e4 on
fabby's agenda
man i like the peace sacrifice earlier
this one it came too late yeah
i don't understand the compensation here
i'm starting to think white has the
compensation well look at the rook on a7
really nice h1 queen h5
yeah yeah i mean
why isn't
it wide attacking right yeah i mean
bishop on d8
time discrepancy wesley so one minute
and 10 seconds meanwhile fabiano carrano
with two minutes on the clock are we
going to see rook b2
sneaky ids
he wants to make sure that f2 is
attacked right so that bishop takes b6
rook takes b6
knight e4 double question mark will be
answered by it takes and f2 is hanging
but can i start with 94 maybe
because knight e4 looks like a great
move the idea is that if the knight is
captured by the bishop don't forget that
the pawn on h7 is under
the threat of matin one you don't have
time to take on e3 he's gone bishop
takes b6 bishop takes b6 knight f3
instead
bishop takes b6 rook b6 and knight f3
yes
it doesn't seem i don't understand that
one i i mean once you see knight e4
with the tempo against the queen i don't
see how you could resist playing that
well maybe he just didn't see it
uh bishop g6 played queen g4 played
quickly
okay makes a lot of sense i guess rook
b2 is coming d5 actually played actually
um
queen g3
feel like compensations yes uh rearing
its head here
f2 is
so soft yes and e4 is coming on wesley's
agenda and you need to defend this pawn
and rook f1
but now we've got options 495 is still
very bad for black right
i don't know if it's very
bad
uh i'm also thinking there's a rook a2
potentially uh re-returning the pin oh
there we go rook f1 e4 knight e5 and
quickly bishop hr yeah actually i took
one of your forces first on
e4 no yeah yeah and the bishop comes
back bishop c4 that bishop has been dead
for a long time but because there is no
pawn on d5 the bishop returns to the
board and also sidestepping any rook a2
pinning possibilities it's a piece
yeah but it's a three result game too
because
it can
it it's three easy to imagine that
something could go wrong e3 e3 queen
takes e3 where where's the what's the
point
he took it and said uh
where is the point and wesley frozen i
think he would have no h6 is not the
point right six was not the point of e3
there was a he just calmly goes back to
it because bishop right now we check
with the pawn on e4 was
was always something that you had to
keep in mind but he just jettisoned the
e pawn for nothing i didn't quite
understand that
blunder just a blunder just
nothing else it's starting to look like
a two horse race if he wins this one
richard report is getting destroyed by
lee kuan lim right now having an amazing
day rook d7 just
now bishop f3 uh no triggering
it's bishop d5 i don't think that helps
you very well he's resigned
knight g6 was knight g6 was coming yeah
nakamura let's take a look at that game
he's playing against chakriar mom and
yaro let's take a quick look at that 2d
board right now this looks very close to
this this one's not worth following we
should go to liquor because this is
nothing with richard there's london
another this is not going to end
anywhere we're wasting time here let's
go to that other game it's very good as
we got it already up let's take a quick
look at the board again to understand
the position white
white looks dominant seven seconds
though
seconds yeah but the position is
dominant and richard doesn't have a lot
either 13 seconds for the hungarian
player needs to make a move knight h5
trying to make some something happen
well bishop
bishop g3
yeah exactly bishop f3 uh driving the
queen
that sacrifice
pieces flying rook c8 coming this is a
three result game absolutely knight
takes b4
the pawn on g3 was under four seconds
three
two five five unclear what the hell oh
great move queen f3 get rid of that
knight
c5 is this so easy yeah this looks
pretty
easy do you take that
on b5 oh the whole house is
six is tender
and now d6 is i mean this is terrible
right rook c7 c7
too many pawns e5
let's go
whoa i think it's going to transfer the
knight to f5 first
not that not bad
no that's a such a gorgeous square there
you go and there you go you're looking
you can't leave the back row without
some mating problems h6 unclear why you
didn't why can't you take on eight six
he's
[Music]
and this should be
no problem wait a minute extra minutes
it's two extra pawns it's he's
definitely winning but he's kind of
hesitant there yeah rookie seven
threatened c6
okay but rook h8 would have meant that
you're whoa whoa whoa whoa
this is not
it's definitely
definitely winning and we would think i
should be able to pull it off
okay but we're there we're there i think
so
h6 is white's agenda okay i think h6 is
coming up next yeah yes it is
h6 he's got that
king
king g8 rook nice nice move keeping your
rook protected
and now f5 is coming there you go
systematic king f6 now rook to d7 that
also works
got to go back rook check and rook f8
let's go
yep
and listening to y'all there's always a
good idea rook cafe is the final nail in
the coffin oh watch out for the
stalemate
richard one last
gasp and that was the final game of this
the penultimate round oh so what
happened day four and the other ones
mamadiarov as we expected did draw
against nakamura okay good round then
for
fabi hikaru drawing yes richard losing
very important him beating wesley
gay clear second clear second that's how
it works that's how it works meanwhile
petersfielder did draw his game against
sam
and jeffrey sean lost with the black
pieces against linear dominguez
whoa results i would not have expected
after jeffrey was really showing that he
does have
some blood scales good blitz skills
lanier yeah well again he's all over the
map all over the map but yeah i'm sure
maurice will tell us exactly what
happened in some of those games
most of them but this one was a dog
fight
all the way throughout lanier was on top
jeffrey claude back and in this position
he's doing well
push it past pawn just push him get some
activity instead he played the move c5
and then after
knight takes e4
rook to b4
bishop takes on c5 he took on e4 and
hung this move king d7 and bishop d6 and
have you seen a worst night in your life
i mean the knight just got frozen out
the game rook to e2 rook g1 and that was
all she wrote he just was able to take
and exploit his other pawn on the
complete other side of the board with
this knight still trapped and lanier
able to win poor jeffrey he was doing
well
so far but now that one knocked him back
i believe to 50
for the day
but the big result is
the game uh of wesley's yeah abby wesley
bobby wesley that one there is is just
massive and uh
i think it was right right around here
you guys were talking about the
sacrifice yes
yeah they texted you for playing after
the after he played it here g4 but it's
not the g4 this moment yes yeah knight
g4 it just says yeah
go for it it looks like a decent
sacrifice
oh good absolutely he missed his chance
the first time when he did it the second
time it was much worse yeah but here
clear definitely taking on g4 and taking
gave a lot of play to black uh king g2
uh the engine gets queen c8 even has an
idea to get the queen coming the pin on
the line these pieces offside surprising
that he didn't take his chance right
here took it later when it was inferior
and fabi defended extremely well in
order to win that game and fabi
rising he looked dead he looked
indeed like he was out of it but rising
like lazarus right fifty percent
therefore hikar i'm sorry for fabiano
caruana karna can wear an extra point on
him today that way karu is performing
well though i'm not trying to take
anything away from it five out of eight
but when you're number one in the world
in blitz you could be losing rating
points by only scoring five out of eight
and he is magnus carlson overtaking him
in the live rating list because of the
amount of draws that hikaro has has
nicked him a little bit below liam still
outperforming everybody with six out of
eight in the blitz oh yeah what an
amazing result and
six out of eight considering he lost to
fabi
uh we're gonna take a look at the end of
the liam game against rockport just like
juan has really shown his stuff in the
blitz portion he has he has uh some
hesitation here
uh with his technique but i really like
the i like the cheapo that richard
rapport was trying to pull on his
opponent with a stalemate and liam uh
recognized
that uh very nicely here
let's see
well you get you go f6 check
uh g e takes f6 okay but who takes with
you yeah of course of course of course
of course
and
yeah two pawns is just a little bit too
much exactly if actually you removed the
e pawn and the f-pawn then that's a
known draw
even though depending on the king
position
yes but with the inclusion of these two
pawns it's just too easy to create a
past e pawn right and bring that pawn to
the end of the board this move h6 very
nice if you take on h6 then
white quickly grabs the rook trades rook
and goes king f6 wins the king upon
ending very routinely very nicely
richard's doing his best just kind of
hanging
hang in there hoping that there will be
a slip up by liam this move f5 very nice
and this move i really like a lot look
the d7 king g8 rook
jack that maneuver
you're going after the f7 pawn you're
more than willing to give away your h6
pawn for that f7 pawn that is
the right thing to do
and rook f8 is the final touch can't
defend the pawn f6 a bit of a hail mary
you know yeah yeah yeah f6 if you take
with the pawn black's king is stalemated
and then you've got this crazy rook
you go regroup
i'm not even sure
it's a draw but okay good no i see it
yeah yeah by the way we should point out
that liam's result has been so fabulous
that he's gained 52 rating points in
blitz
and he's now jumped 19 places in the
world i believe he's number 24 in the
world right now which i'd surprised that
he was that far
down actually on the list but
showing his stuff having a fantastic
performance hikaru dropping with his
performance jeffrey is
oh sorry
wesley has also dropped to number four
in the world as he shed
rating points as well 25 points
wesley
wesley said
and maurice on that note you said that
hikaru dropped
points how many points five out of eight
come on that's a nice result you're
number one in the world you're 2800 you
can't be scoring that number you got to
score
much better that's a lot of points i
mean uh
wow right yeah yeah it is
a reminder that tomorrow is our last day
of the saint louis draft and blitz don't
miss it we have nine more exciting
rounds for you yes hikaru nakamura is a
favorite but you've seen that gap close
in the last couple of rounds and the
summer of chess is by no means over in
fact it flares anew because immediately
after
this grand chess tour we have the fifth
and final leg
the granddaddy of a wall the sink fuel
cup the sink field cup a traditional
tournament here in st louis that is
going to be
wonderful absolutely that will be a
classical chess event and wesley losing
what man for the grand chess tour that's
huge oh yeah i didn't even think about
it just just now but that's it maxime is
again maxine
keep going keep going everybody and fabi
would get 10 points if he comes in
second
so he gets to
doesn't put him in contention but that's
a big ten point all depends on what
happens with wesley right uh chakriar
he'd be within range
uh if you get a jacket
right now what a favorite to get five
points would you say something like that
and he only be at 23 if bobby could
think that's not bad i get some chances
wesley
if wesley gets five or six
we'll put him away from fabi you'd have
to hope for disastrous results but
whatever happens for fabi now remember
he did play two events and he got
seven grand chess tour points that was
ten two events terrible i mean seriously
yeah richard got five and a half in one
uh poppy's
the only person who performed worse was
rajabov who
is not playing here but seven in two
events
but if he could get 10 points here and
jump to 17
okay he might even think about winning
the same field cup he may not win the
whole thing
but he could get a 50 000
also bonus for coming in second on the
grand chess tour so that would be
amazing for him as well he's just
exactly he's right in there for some
extra money third is 25 000. nice
bonuses
huge bonuses and they're going to be
fighting for it all it's the last blitz
round of the day we're going to take a
short break here to get some
calculations going we'll be right back
with the final round of action of the
day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it's the last round of the
saint louis wrapper and blitz blitz day
number one
we still have another nine rounds
tomorrow but for now this is how we
finish the day rap out against corona
normally would be our game to watch
number three against number two but
check it out it's the two best
performers of the day hikaw nakamura
facing against elek wang lia who's
simply on fire six points out of eight
it's too bad he didn't have a better
rapid result and he's not really
fighting for those top places but that's
going to be the game that we focus on
absolutely and hikaru if hikaro wins
this game then he will actually tie with
liam for the best results because liam's
leading by a point that's right six out
of nine would be the score for both of
us certainly liam has no interest in
that he wants to be accumulating more
and more points absolutely is the two be
prepared to face off for this ninth and
ultimate game for this day four of the
st louis rapid and blitz and here we go
we're all like anxious
touch the clock
let's fire up
the time yeah d4 none of this berlin
draw business anymore let's take a look
at him indian we've seen so many from
hikaru but they've all been from the
other side exactly he's saying hey that
queen c2 is becoming annoying let me
play the white side of it for a change
let me see how the
h6 and this is becoming pretty topical
to play bishop h4 g5 bishop g3 knight c6
yeah with cd5 and ed5 included i was
just
mentally i was trying to make the
gymnastics of a283
and how that compares with other
variations knight c6
voluntarily putting the i mean often
times you see a queen a4 check to try to
induce a knight c6 there's a lot of
recent theory here following the moves
g5 bishop g3 knight e4
and how would that theory actually go
because we're about to see it for
craziness actually after knight e4
there are some dubious moves but i think
that developing the oh h5 which is
another by the way way of playing this
position both knight h5 have been s8
recently
h5
yes
it's the newest and greatest
latest and greatest opening theory holy
smokes h5 so h4 knight e4 i get that
part but f3
[Music]
f3 is a move it's just a move so it's
supposed to be okay for black right
okay he has not gone for it
sorry he did
he did go for the commentator's curse
the moment we say no not gonna happen
yeah so i'm assuming queen e7 because
otherwise
white gets to play bishop to d3 and
knight e2 for free so you've got to do
something
to keep this initiative
eventually these pawns on h5 and g5 are
going to be weak and they're between e7
king d2 yeah you couldn't play bishop f2
because of the trick with knight takes
d4 that would have that would have been
embarrassing with the king still on e1
knight takes d4 was a threat so
with the move king d2 we defend e3
stopping queen e3 as well as
making e3 takes d4 possible h4 chasing
the bishop back to f2
okay i i agree my king's a little bit
uncomfortable
but again if i can
just complete my development with bishop
d392
i'm going to have everything and i mean
complete mastery of the center
queenside king side where does black's
king go in these variations usually
queenside yeah usually
bishop e6 castles is on black agenda and
then you start playing for g4 which
chicago has already stopped right he
doesn't want to see any of that business
a6 i assume was designed to prevent the
bishop from coming to b5 where it would
disturb the knight and make sure that
black's king is not
going queen side so we do have bishop d3
h3 important tempo just
i like black's position bishop d6 is
another tempo night before being
threatened that's why we see the move a3
do you like black's position i'm seeing
bad bad bad uh things happening here to
black i'm i'm sorry yeah i'm saying
92 rook d
okay
as white
knight e2 bring my rooks to the center
and then i get to play
for e3 e4
that's what i'm that's what it's all
about in my view
no
my rook's on e1
short castle
king side baby
what are we happy with that decision
that's an amazing decision rook to g1
and
g4 almost plays itself doesn't it
sure i've got to say i
i talk about it the king goes yeah well
you were you you were so kind enough to
suggest it was going queen side but rook
g1 and g3
uh white gets to pry open the king's
side no question about it
um
i'm very confused that would have
castled queen said without a hundred
percent 100
didn't see that one coming
and we are being told that wesley so
very quickly won his game big time
blunder bye dude hitler huge results big
for wesley big for the grand chester mvl
is unhappy with peter svidler he's not
getting a he's not getting a christmas
card this year
okay but back to our game
saying i don't want to commit all my
rooks to the king side let me play rook
e1 and contribute with your plan right
king c1 e4 and all that kind of stuff
yeah you kind of tuck your king away but
boy i gotta tell you i mean when
opportunity like rook g1 and g3 knocks
you answer the door
um
okay okay he is it is what it is and
black's king is still not what you call
save yeah not at all
uh rook f1 okay that's another move that
i would have
i would have
kept an obeying so i would have played
the move king b-1 first all right qb one
at least played we understand that move
i like white i would like black if the
king was on v8 i think it's so bad
exactly and i think e3 e4 i mean white
is you know like just
revved it up and now it's time to
unleash the kraken e3 e4 blowing open
the position
hopefully uh
white's pieces are ready to take
advantage of all the open lines and
files
that will occur and they will occur
because you do not want to see
well
it's all been chopped pawn takes e4 pawn
takes e4 pawn takes you for knight takes
e4
right
i think
[Music]
94 and maybe bishop can come to c4 that
bishop c4 maybe is that on the board
pardon me no uh he played knight takes
e4 there was a knight d5 played almost
ala tempo
okay so black is
holding
a grip
over the f4 square for the d5
right
yes it is an isolated pawn absolutely
again i would love hikaru's position
sorry that queen exposition if the king
was on the v8 yeah like the king
now the king does look
like wide open you know on
the g8 squared knight on e4 to c3
that was a very difficult and decision
but it was made quickly nonetheless an
idea for played by laguang liam
he did decide after all to take on f4
i'm having troubles with this bishop on
that's why he plays d5
explosive move there by hikaru nakamura
why cannot can i not take that pawn
well he's thinking that okay let me just
let me catch up with the players okay
wait hold on we have a lot of moves
there knight takes the three rook takes
e6 what's going on our board is
missing up there there are no two
knights it's only one night knight takes
e4 knight takes f4 knight except for d5
on the board what happened
there is no knight on that f4 i'm not
really sure why the uh board is going
we're gonna go with live as there is no
knight on f4 right queen on h7 what's
going on there's a pit on this bishop
yesterday how do you defend this bishop
oh you definitely like that there you go
but if i and if i attack it again bishop
c5 let's say hey we do have knight e4 oh
you do oh no i just take it
no i don't i'm sorry so
knight d1 yeah well maybe knight d1
although it's a bit sad of a move now i
agree with that wholeheartedly uh there
is a trick that maybe e
6 e7
could somehow turn things around between
f5
right now
but what if i just move my king
somewhere
i'm not really sure where again i do
have knight d1 as a potential defense
to this ugly pin
that is currently
i'm facing king h are we going king h7 i
assume i don't know what i don't know if
there's a difference between king h7 and
king and jade but can you trade bishop
before never mind it goes to h7 let me
show you
[Laughter]
right e8 played instead i don't like e8
okay
letting
a little bit knight c5 by the way knight
c5 instead of rook to e8 would have just
picked off the e pawn
that makes a lot of sense to me yep but
naka feeling the pressure nevertheless
you've got to come up with some move
queen takes b7
knight f2 no i don't think so quintex b7
doesn't seem real well i mean i'm just
saying that the knight on f2
i get to re reverse look at this how
much seven check i like that oh king h7
and where's the follow up knight e4 what
a move it takes advantage of the fact
that the queen on f5 is overloaded f7 s7
what is the it's the soft spot queen f7
queen e4 queen takes e4 queen f7 check
is the soft spot wait can i take on e7
with the rook
don't forget
yeah but i'm attacking the knight twice
so take c7 queen takes d3 i have queen
takes so rook e7 knight g5
knight g5 check is just getting some
time and but naka's going to find knight
g5
6 knight f3
knight f3 who where are you walking
knight f3 bishop d4 no negative three i
have to chop that bishop you don't want
to allow that bishop away to sneak out
nine three there you go i haven't done
it
right bishop takes h4 bishop d4 on
white's agenda that's why
alejandro wants to get rid of that white
bishop on f2 he doesn't do it okay two
let's go should do he should not want to
give away his advantage he wants to keep
the game whoa
d4 forks the queen and the rook
what's going on queen takes f2
no but then have queen e6
knight d
bishop
bishop before i was gonna go knight to
d4 he put his bishop on d4 instead
knight d4 was forking the queen on rook
you said queen f2 no i don't know queen
of two
i don't believe myself i think maybe
maybe maybe that was the move
maybe like down to 15 seconds oh oh i
no way there must be a trick here
how do you get away with a move like
that that is remarkable
what is the refutation though i know i i
so badly want to play knight h4 but i
don't see it
instantly bishop f4
his players are so resourceful it's
crazy it truly is 10 seconds on his
clock knock it down to 24 seconds
and somehow the guy's not dead i know
you won one and just keeping the king
there's four attacking the bishop
defending the pawn on b7 i don't know if
anybody's watching that i'm watching the
queen f7 huge move
this feels like trouble big feels like
trump time there goes a knight queen
check the queen takes c5 that's it
that queen f7
rocked liam time to decide
covered
and big win for hikaru nakamura in that
game against le quang liam we're gonna
have to analyze that a little bit
further further let's take a look at
bobby versus rapport what is going on i
what that there's a queen there's rooks
i have no idea it could end in a draw
right now if there's a perpetual check
and i actually don't see anything better
for white because b2 is hanging some
some echoes of uh
yeah the queen versus the two rooks
and at this time now you don't have a
perpetual as well yeah is hanging yeah
what did he do
because b2 is hanging right nine seconds
for five
ten seconds for richard rapport and
dropping but rook takes p2 is just a
huge threat how do you defend that
exactly it's not just rook b2 i'm
worried about it's rook b2 and rook g2
now this is lost right that's losing
but it's not made yet
for the two rooks it could be it should
be it's not right it should be
where's the mate
and they're just blitzing now anything
could happen remember
remember it was it was rapport two rooks
the queen's easier to play with it looks
like he's going to just have to take the
draw
to be smart just take the repetition
really there's no mate here that's
remarkable to me this is i think it's a
smart thing to do is just take it your
time is looking f4 what
why didn't he play rook four
because he had no time on the
where's my win i mean
richard i mean
okay putting that last and lester
as we see jeffrey zhang versus shakriar
and jeffrey up upon
but that bond shouldn't go anywhere
right
[Music]
no no
and just check check all kinds of checks
upon on g3 exactly there's no way you
win this right
well i like the way
jeffrey just kind of shoveled his king
towards the g3 pawn and okay okay okay
draw
okay okay
okay
yeah and another result sam shanklin
drew against linear dominguez
i want to check out that game that
wesley so beat
peters fiddler it was over quickly
that one doesn't have much intrigue it
doesn't it was it an opening blunder was
just a terrible move we'll we'll look at
it let's look at this one though this
one with fabi uh at the end he was this
game was crazy it was definitely an edge
for
white throughout but then the game
turned and again you saw that he could
have should have taken his draw but he
didn't and this position very
clear win for him although it's not the
kind of thing you just suspect would
have immediately happened the idea here
guard your knight swing this move is
forced and now this move rook to g3 and
this sets everything up now there's no
way to stop this move rook check queen
of seven would have stopped you if you
put it on a1 but by putting it here
you're just in trouble i'm going to take
a pawn like you did in the game and now
it's going to be mate check your king
has to go straight back and now check
making you decide where are you going to
go
and if you go g1 then simply rook takes
d3 and there you go it's mate and if you
go to e1 then rook takes h3 and it's
mate what's funny is
how richard mated fabi
with two rooks against a queen
in their rapid game and now favi could
have returned a favor yeah that would
have been poetic justice nice
to get this one back but didn't happen
and the game ended in a draw in time
pressure now the game with peter and
wesley
uh
the bad news happened for peter
back here
uh
in fact let's go just a little bit
further to this position and here he
played the move g5 which is fine and
bishop g3 which is fine but then he
played the shocker d5 okay that is kind
of crazy and that's just like
whoa you're just going to open up the
game like that well you can't
b4
move your rook away
rook leaves
queen f3
defends your knight you can't you move
it we take your pawn and your position
just collapses just a straight blunder
one
a big one really bad so it wasn't that
an interesting game just a bad move
falling at the finish line was peter
there's got to be a lot of fatigue for
the players nine rounds of blitz but a
great result for wesley to be sure as he
tries to keep pace
uh definitely let's take a look at the
standings to see just where we stand at
the moment big time win by hicaro in the
very last round to
really cement his lead alejandro
absolutely it's still a two and a half
point lead over fabiano caruana richard
rapport currently in third place having
a disastrous day three and a half out of
nine a minus two score wesley saw
meanwhile with plus one is surging a bit
up there 14 points shakriar five out of
nine how's he still up there i don't
understand it i mean it's remarkable but
he is in some kind of position as far as
the grand chess tour goes you know do
you know what's crazy no look at that
look at that list yeah where are the
players in the grand chess tour on this
list the ones who are playing for the
grand chest
position third third fourth and fifth
second through fifth they're all they're
all right there right over take out
hikaru and you know that one mexican
they grab is like how is this happening
right they're all at the top they're all
in contention right incredible really
remarkable that all the the players in
the grand chess tour
we have six wild cards and on the top
five there are there's only one it's
only hikaru it's only hikaru spoiling
the apple cart
and that he and here is our grand chess
tour as we see mvl
on top but
soon to be surpassed
for sure
definitely by wesley maybe prom
depending on tomorrow's results by
shakira mediaro and once again everybody
uh the fast and furious weekend
continues tomorrow sunday we'll have our
final day of day five of the grand chess
tour st louis rapid and blitz
you have a special guest in the studio
alejandro and of course we have a great
lineup of great blitz players but
we have a former world blitz champion
with us here in the studio it's like
liam
indeed despite the hiccup at the end he
still had a fantastic day time for best
score of the day
welcome to the show you had a poor first
half with the rapid that certainly
wasn't what you wanted but you right in
the ship in the blitz a little couple of
hiccups how do you feel about your
performance so far yeah i'm very happy
about today i think today i scored six
boys so that's equal to the previous
three days combined so
yeah relatively speaking i should be
happy with my performance today but i
feel like i could have done a little bit
better especially the last game against
hikaru
but in general i think i play much
better today and
at least i think i avoid the last place
now so that's my goal for today
you
you are a great blitz player you won the
world blitz title what's the difference
between blitz and rapid you think that
makes it such a big differential
yeah in in bliss it's a lot about
playing fast and trying to avoid
blunders you don't have to play
brilliant chess you just have to play
decent chess and avoid blenders and try
to be a little bit faster than your
opponents so
i mean it takes a lot more practice to
be good at rapid and classical than in
place i would say because simply it's
more like your natural ability you just
push the pieces and see how they go
have you always been good at blitz is
something that you did as a child or
that you practiced when you were younger
yeah i think when i was younger i played
a lot more bliss than recently
so i won the world bliss championship in
2013 and
since then i didn't play too much please
but apparently i still remember how to
play you still got it well we hope to
see you do well tomorrow as i'll close
out the event congratulations thank you
liam i can't help but ask this final
round game that you played with hikaru
you made a decision that frankly
alejandro and i thought was
extraordinary you decided to castle
kingside right here and we thought
absolutely for certain your moves a7 a6
and queen e7 that you were preparing to
put your king on the queen side
how did you come up with this decision
castle's short
yeah to be honest when i played a6 i
didn't plan where my king would go but i
thought a6 was important to prevent
something coming to b5 like maybe the
bishop coming to b5 uh after a3 bishop
b6 maybe bishop maybe knight b5 all
right so i wanted to control that square
and then when it was time to castle i
mean that that's also one thing in place
you shouldn't plan too far ahead because
you
don't have that much time so you just
kind of take it
uh step by step and here when it was
time to castle i decided to cast a shot
because
honestly the king feels
safer on
on the king side because if i cut so
along then b4 b5 or like a4 something
coming to a6 or c5 that concerns you the
problem that we had with castles and
hikaru did not play it hikaru actually
played rook on a1 to e1 we were thinking
that the king
you you were ready for
rook a1 the g1 liam yeah i consider that
move definitely and i thought that was
the best move
i thought i have to go knight g3 to stop
him from playing g3 i see and then
probably knight takes a bishop takes i
don't know
right and somehow you're in that sg
planning to keep the king side closed
yeah i think it's still not so easy for
him to open up the king side fair enough
thank you so very much and again our
congratulations really you regaled us
with your great quality of blitz good
luck tomorrow thank you yes sir
absolutely
knight g3 that was the answer well
sometimes we just don't find them yeah
we missed it absolutely no a great
amount of resources were found in that
game by both sides i did think that
mayor happs liam tried a little too hard
at some point to keep the pieces alive
hicaro finding that crazy at midnight c3
to b1 yeah knight 3b1 was shocking but
then queen f7 queen f8 queen takes c5
and the knight on b1 is wonderful like
everything just worked like what how
does that work out like that we have a
lot more chess coming not today but
tomorrow we will finish the st louis
rapid and blitz and we have much more to
come
the ultimate tournament in america chess
the grand chester sink field cup august
16th to 27th
put that in your calendar and come and
watch the action
then the ultimate loops ultimate moves
on september 7th followed by the return
of fischer random chaz known as chess
960 that'll be september 8th through
10th and if you like to see those
americans battle each other well guess
what it's the american champion us
championship coming back to st louis
october 5th through the 19th
very nice our favorite tournament wow
absolutely
and with us we have somebody that's
familiar with winning some of those
tournaments yes yeah no caruana
indeed the number two player in the
world fabiano carano with us fabi today
felt like
a roller coaster ride a little bit
maybe not so crazy but
what were you experiencing because we
were looking at it thinking the guy is
falling like a rock and then all of a
sudden you rose back again
yeah it was a wild day um
i mean i started badly i wasn't playing
well i i was blundering i i'm
i mean
those two back-to-back games against
jeffrey uh losing
i think dead drawn rukandin and then
against shakuya was a horrible game
so i wasn't feeling too good and then
and then against sam was also a very bad
game but somehow i won that one
uh and after that things improved um
last game was of course also
wild and and ridiculous but uh
because i
started badly the
my my feeling now is more
um
kind of happy with today if it was other
way around i would have been upset
well
is it is it just
like you said the sam game you get a
break and then it goes in your direction
because it's hard to control
how we think when we're on tilt or we're
losing games
you didn't do anything special to come
back you said you basically is what i'm
hearing yeah i actually don't think i
was on tilt
i mean sometimes i get tilted when i'm
playing badly but
i didn't
feel massively upset i think i was just
not not in shape i was just making
mistakes which had nothing to do with
it's not like i was doing crazy things
it's just that once i was getting down
to
to the last few seconds uh my my play
was really suffering
but yeah then after that game against
them i actually i think played two
pretty good games um
i mean not perfect of course but but for
blitz i think pretty decent games and
then the last game was wild but uh
i can't even be upset of course i was
winning at the end pretty easily but he
was also winning for most of the game so
i can't really be upset
uh we actually saw you at two rooks and
could have made it him you ended up
getting mated by him uh yesterday with
with history i had that thought you had
you did i thought i thought it would be
poetic justice um but
my works aren't as good as his
finally
it looks like hikaru was going to win
this with
seemingly running away with the score is
it important for you to come in second
place
i don't know the scores i mean i i know
that he's uh in the lead i don't know
how massively in the lead i assume it's
pretty much an uncatchable lead but i
mean i wasn't thinking about first place
at the start of today you know like
after after i was minus three i was just
trying to
to not lose any more games just to
stabilize things um the fact that i'm
still in a pretty good position i'm
happy with um i don't know
i don't know who
who's behind me or how much
he's two and a half points ahead of you
by the way yeah i mean i i don't think
that i'm
catching up with two and a half points
especially since he carver is playing
well
um so yeah it would be nice to uh secure
second place if possible that would be
good all right well
keep bouncing back enough of the roller
coaster rides well if i bounce back i
have to do badly so you're
i think you did badly already
let's hope you just rise thanks good
luck
very nice
fabby just a quick question for you as
two players have distinguished
themselves in this first day of blitz uh
liam and uh
hikaru scored six
out of nine your quick thoughts of those
two players
well i mean they're both very good blitz
players we're not too surprised by that
i mean hikaru is a specialist in blitz
and
um
and yeah the fact that he he also did
very well in rapid
i guess it's not good for the rest of us
that he's also finding his foreign blitz
and liam i think started even better
than he finished he might be a bit
disappointed with the end because um i
think he was plus four after six rounds
so he was really
really running away with it but uh it's
hard to come back because of the scoring
system from a tough
uh from a bad rapid result like you have
thank you and good luck tomorrow fabi
thanks absolutely like one liam as
specialist in blitz but hikaru nakamura
just managed to stop him there at the
end absolutely and it was it was a great
game i mean three results and they can't
deploy right it was like 13 seconds 13
seconds and somehow carl has this
annoying habit of he keeps pulling
those really really close games he tends
to do very well in the close close games
and liam always was mentioning how
important it is not to blunder in blitz
and it's like consistency can see
everything he might not find the
absolute best move but does hikaru fully
blunder almost never
no no no he's he's remarkably consistent
is what i want to want to add absolutely
nakamura well he is the top blitz player
in the world for a reason and he is
joining us here in the studio
well your word was consistent he was
plus three in
uh the rapid and now he's plus three in
the blitz hikaru
you had
a good day today
not like all the games were smooth
though but when it seemed like there
might have been some trouble
you were able to pull it off right at
those moments yeah i mean i think uh i
mean it started off very smoothly but
certainly towards the end there were a
couple games that weren't great the last
one was probably the worst of the day
against uh against lee and um you know i
got a little bit lucky but kind of i
think as as alejandro and jasper were
saying
i was able to just find moves that
weren't pure blunders even when i was
much worse and just kept the game going
and i was also a little bit fortunate
that uh the quang missed this 94 move
which uh fortunately i saw when i played
e7 i was i was really happy when i found
it i knew that if i could untangle with
the time situation there was no way he
could defend so it was a good finish and
um i feel very good with the result you
have a big lead two and a half points
it's kind of hard to imagine anybody
catching you do you worry about things
like that and when you're going into
tomorrow are you thinking
run up the score play just keep playing
chess or keep the lead and be
conservative yeah i mean there are a
couple possibilities so like the first
game today against richard is a good
example of this where um the game was a
draw it was the same draw that we played
in in the rapid rapid portion and um uh
richard basically after the game he said
well i'm sure you wouldn't play this
line again he thought that i would try
to be aggressive and try to beat him
with black in the first game and you
know i think there are there are a
couple ways to look at you can sort of
play very aggressively and and hope
things work out of course if they don't
you look very stupid you can also just
be solid um you know in the process if
i'm solid i think there's a good chance
i'll win this tournament but there's
also a good chance that i might draw too
many games and lose that number one
ranking in blitz so you know kind of
there there are many ways of looking at
it but i think for me i'm just trying to
play good chess like i'm i'm not uh
i'm not really worried about anything so
playing playing good games you look very
relaxed let's talk about that number one
ranking in blitz and as you said you
could win this tournament looks like you
got a great chance but the number one
ranking does matter to you
nah it doesn't matter at all really i i
mean to to be blunt if i was worried
about that number one ranking it would
kind of be like playing online where i
wouldn't play this event because i think
when i look at the ratings of the
players here i have to score something
insane i think there's some players like
sam for example who i think he's
underrated definitely in rapid but i
think also in blitz like
in the rapid i played sam i drew the
game and he had this ridiculous 26.09
rating which of course is 100 points
below where he should be at least so
uh if i was really worried about the
rating then i thought i just wouldn't
play the event so i think it's kind of
silly to worry about those things of
course it's nice but again um i just i
just want to play good chess and if i do
that maybe i'll gain ranking but most
importantly i would say i just i do want
to try and win the tournament at this
point so that probably will dictate how
i play tomorrow all right we're looking
forward to seeing you close it out sure
our congratulations akara very very fine
performance indeed certainly let's take
a look at the standings remember nine
more rounds of blitz coming up tomorrow
it is hikaru nakamura with a commanding
two and a half point lead richard
rapport is trailing fabiano carolina by
a point in the fight for second place
but don't forget about wesley seoul only
one and a half points away from his
compatriot
with those grand chess tour points all
up for grabs everything can happen in
one more day of blitz alejandro will be
here same time same place nine more
rounds of blitz and if we need playoffs
we'll have those for you as well
immediately after and guys i think
that's it for today i can't well just
final thoughts for maurice just just
just just bring it home for us maurice i
just heard the word playoffs
see how relaxed the guy was he's like
yeah yeah i'm just going to play a good
chance yeah
nobody's catching him he's got this one
on lockdown it would take a disaster of
epic proportions for him to lose this
event but it is important as far as the
grand chester standings are concerned
for him
for the rest of the field to at least
get some good points and so expect to
see a very motivated wesley soh richard
report chakrabar madeira fabiana caruana
that's going to be a heavy duty battle
as we're going to go into the sink field
cup i don't think chicago is playing in
this infield cup right so that's going
to be
the big deal and tomorrow will decide
all of that as maxine vashila grav is
watching in the wings so we expect very
exciting games tomorrow as they look to
put themselves in good position for the
finals so don't miss it we'll be here
calling all the action
thank you maurice no thank you yasser
this was an exciting day
let's get ourselves some good night's
sleep and we will be back nine rounds of
blitz to finish this tournament and
that's gonna be great don't miss it good
night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st louis chess club is
prohibited
you
you